die
So Leute, bin ich am Start, auf geht's!
Erstmal kurz das Headset entknoten.
So, wunderbar, sehr schön, jetzt passt das.
Die Hacker-Mans sind auch schon wieder da, ich sehe es 15 Uhr, normale Leute arbeiten
noch, die Hacker-Mans sind schon da.
Was soll ich sagen, ich arbeite ja auch nicht.
Gut, das liegt daran, weil ich heute frei habe, aber sonst als Studenten, stimmt, lull.
Da habe ich jetzt ja gar nicht dran gedacht, sowas gibt es ja auch noch.
So, ich habe heute mal zur Abwechslung einen Plan, was wir im Stream machen wollen.
Ich erkläre euch jetzt gleich, was wir machen wollen.
Wir müssen uns erst noch mal eine Runde in den richtigen Hacker-Mode begeben, damit
das heute was wird.
Dazu muss man 5 Minuten einfach das hier angucken und schon erstmal richtig in der Hacker-Zone
angelangt.
Dann kann man solche Videos drehen auf YouTube wie Boy Dreams of Code oder so komische Videos.
Da gibt es hier auf YouTube einen Schwachsinn, Boy Dreams in Code oder irgendwie sowas.
This 14 year old prodigy has released 15 apps oder irgendwie sowas.
Diese Videos sind so kacke.
Vor allem, du musst ja voll das krasse prodigy sein, wenn du irgendeine Hallo Welt App in
capstone pusht.
Wobei, ist das überhaupt das richtige Wort?
Prodigy heißt doch irgendwie sowas wie super begabt oder sowas oder?
Wunder, ein Wunder, Wunder Kind, genau ja sowas.
Lerne, wie du 5000 Euro am Tag im Schlafen findest.
Oh Leute, ich habe letztens einen Fehler gemacht, ich muss euch mal sagen.
Ich habe auf YouTube gesucht, ich habe auf YouTube gesucht, sowas wie how to monetize
website.
Hab ich geguckt, ob es zu AdSense noch eine sinnvolle Alternative gibt.
Alter, du wirst ja erschlagen mit irgendwelchen Gurus, die dir erklären, wie du, wenn du
einen Wordpress Blog aufmachst, auf einmal Millionär wirst.
Es ist total, es ist so fail diese Videos, was es da gibt.
Es ist noch mal, das ist ja, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche, wie macht man die Basics und
irgendwelche Fake-Guru-Leute, die dir auf YouTube das krasse Business erklären, die
erklären dir das krasse AdSense-Business.
Du brauchst auch noch CEO, CEO brauche ich dann, aber mit S, search engine optimizers.
Ich muss die Basics, ich habe heute ein Video aufgenommen, wo ich durch den Wald gelaufen
bin im Schnee, guckt hier, sieben Minuten, sinnlos vor mich hingeschwänzt, Schnee-Stell-Teil-Zwei
am Start.
Hier bin ich heute rumgelaufen und habe ich mir gedacht, wenn du schon gerade am rumlaufen
bist im Wald, im Schnee, dann nimm einfach mal was auf.
White Mode, das ist das Gegenteil von Dark Mode und jetzt, und jetzt Plot-Twist, ich
war gar nicht draußen, das ist mein Desktop-Hintergrund.
So, also, Gag-Wait, so Leute, ich sag euch was wir heute machen, aber nach, aber wir machen
erst mal kurz andere Musik an, exquisite, cat-jam, also was wir heute machen ist folgendes,
was ist aus den Videos geworden, wo du passanten unfreiwillig gefilmt hast, du meinst das
vor ein paar Wochen, ja das habe ich auch noch, also du meinst, wo ich den letzten Schnee-Stell
aufgenommen habe, wo ein paar Leute durchs Bild gelaufen sind, ja das habe ich auch
noch, aber die heutige Variante, die heutige war besser.
Max, es ist wieder an der Zeit, dass du Dreamland anmachst, nee das ist nicht Dreamland, das
ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, was du meinst ist glaube ich das da, oder, das da, exellent.
fantastic, holes, dont puff TRO-M, ich werte das als Kompliment,
Find ich auch, wir sind es ja auch nicht umsonst, jeder Sub increase den Chat-IQ um eins
Okay genug
Also ich zeige euch jetzt was wir machen und nachdem wir die richtig geilen Hacker-Mens sind, schreiben wir das natürlich in Wim
Was auch sonst, ja
So, erstmal kurz fullscreen machen, kurz was getrunken
Also, was wir heute machen ist, genau ich bin schon bei Hetzner eingeloggt und ich habe jetzt ein Stream-Projekt gemacht, guck mal, guck mal
Ich habe ein default-Projekt, ein nicht öffnen Projekt, da ich nicht wieder Dinger leake im Stream und ein Stream-Projekt
Beste
Also, was wir heute machen ist folgendes, als erstes
Oh, das ist natürlich
Wir sind noch, wir sind noch, wir haben noch mehr IQ bekommen durch das letzte Video
Wir sparen uns einfach erstens, zweitens, drittens, sondern benutzen die Zeilen-Nummern dafür
Das ist erstens, das ist zweitens, das ist drittens, automatische Zeilen-Nummer, Numerierung, exzellent
Also, das erste was wir heute machen ist
Ja, erstmal Schrift größer, größer
So, das erste was wir heute machen ist, wir installieren ein Proxy auf einem Hetzner-Server, irgendein Squid oder so
Und 10 IPs
Also, also
Mit 10 IPs und Proxy
So, und was wir da machen ist folgendes, und zwar BigBrain, ich hatte gestern Abend eine super Idee
Und zwar, es kommt ja vor, dass wenn der Preis-Champ crawlt
Das ab und zu, der mal geplockt wird bei Amazon oder anderen Seiten, da hab ich mir gedacht, hm, woran liegt das?
Ja klar, weil man von der gleichen IP zu oft auf den jeweiligen Shop zugreift
Deswegen machen wir einen Server
Der kriegt 10 Public-IPs drauf, ein Proxy drauf
Und den Proxy stellen wir so ein, dass der die Request randomist auf 10 ausgehende IPs
Das heißt im Endeffekt, bei jeder Verbindung kriegen wir eine random IP als Absender-IP
Und die Seiten plocken uns nicht mehr, plocken uns nicht mehr so schnell
Ist das dann ein Rotating-Proxy? Das ist ein Coggers-Proxy
Heute kommt kein Kubernetes-Stuff, aber ich kann euch sagen, es kommt richtig BigBrain-Zeug, falls er so funktioniert, wie ich mir das gedacht hab
Also das ist das erste, was wir machen
Dann machen wir das mal hier, finde ich dann eh nicht mehr
So, das ist das erste, was wir machen mit 10 IPs und Proxy
Mal gucken, was wir mit dem Squid machen, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wahrscheinlich
Squid-Config ist zwar pain in the ass, aber es funktioniert
Nico, 12 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub
Huge Sub, Dankeschön für den Sub
So, und danach wird es noch viel, viel advanceder, was wir heute machen
Also, mal gucken, wie lange das dauert
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so großartig kompliziert ist
Weil ich meine, wir müssen Server installieren, das sind 3 Klicks
Wir müssen uns darauf einloggen, 10 IPs anlegen und Squid installieren
Und die Squid-Config anpassen, dann sind wir wahrscheinlich in einer halben Stunde fertig, hoffe ich mal
So, und dann machen wir folgendes
Dann kommt 100% DevOps Action
Also dann machen wir folgendes
Wir nehmen den Preis-Champ, das Repo vom Preis-Champ
Und machen uns das Leben ein bisschen einfacher
Weil aktuell habe ich es ja so gemacht, ich habe da nichts automatisiert an Deployment
Wenn ich aktuell den Preis-Champ deployen will
Nein, wir machen es ohne GitHub Actions, GitHub Actions haben wir mal schon gemacht in einem Stream
Aber wir machen auch was, was nice ist
Wir machen die absolut DevOps Lite-Variante, aber die ich auch sehr schön finde
Wir machen keine eigene Container-Registry, wir machen kein Kubernetes, wir machen kein GitHub Actions
Wir machen aber was anderes
Was ist mit Vim?
Ja gut, Vim ist halt einfach der Hacker-Man-Editor
Die meisten Leute haben ja schon das Problem wieder rauszukommen
Vim ist glaube ich der einzige Editor, der vorneweg 4 Plus-Varianten hat, wie man rauskommt
Außer Emacs dann vielleicht noch mehr
So, und Plopswasher
Dankeschön für 7 Monate, exzellent, ja das weiß ich auch nicht, du sollst einfach aufhören zu arbeiten
Und noch ein paar Subsgif, exquisite
Du kannst ja nebenbei zugucken, im Zweifelsfall später im VOD
So, also, das ist das nächste was wir machen, wie gesagt
Wir machen einen Docker-File für den Preis-Champ
Dann machen wir einen Docker-Compose für den Preis-Champ
Dann haben wir einen Git-Post-Receive-Hook
Und in dem Git-Post-Receive-Hook
Machen wir dann Restart-Container-Off-Server
Also, so habe ich mir das überlegt
Also sprich, wir machen einen Docker-File
Da wird der Preis-Champ in den Container gepackt
Also, kann man den Preis-Champ in den Container packen lassen
Dann machen wir einen Compose-File
Da schreiben wir dann so Dinge drin, wie welcher Port soll benutzt werden
Und wie bildet man das Ganze und sowas
Das checken wir alles ins Preis-Champ-Git-Repo ein
Und dann machen wir auf dem Server einen Git-Repo mit Post-Receive-Hook
Und wenn wir dann da reinpushen
Dann bildet er auf dem Server jedes Mal den Preis-Champ
Und startet ihn neu
Das heißt, was wir dann im Endeffekt nur noch machen müssen ist
Ein neues Commit
Committen
Also neue Änderungen machen
Puschen
Und das Server aktualisiert sich selbstständig neu und lädt die neueste Variante
Soweit die Theorie
Gucken, ob das funktioniert
Exquisite
Ja
So, wir fangen mal mit einfachen Sachen an
Bis 22 in Jurevice, ich glaube, wir sind schneller
Wir fangen mal anders an
Zwar
Wir legen uns erstmal den Server an
Das kleinste, was es gibt
Es wird echt Zeit, dass ich von Hetzner gesponsert werde
So viel Hetzner, wie ich hier zeige
Leute, Nurenberg
Nurenberg
Nurenberg oder Falkenstein
Nurenberg, Helsinki
Wir können auch mal
Wir können auch mal nach Finnland
Ey, wir gehen heute nach Falkenstein
Beste
So, Ubuntu 20.04, Paa Plus, kleinster Server, reicht
Wobei, ich bin nicht ganz sicher
Ich glaube, wir brauchen ja nicht lang
Ich nehme mal, dass es ein bisschen schneller geht
Den Dreikörner
Da haben wir genug
Acht Euro im Monat, den mache ich nach dem Stream wieder weg
Da müssen wir uns nicht langweilen
Bis da irgendwas durch ist
Dreikörner
Ich finde es übrigens echt nice, dass Hetzner auch einen Dreikörner im Angebot hat
Das ist so eine gute Kombination aus
Ich brauche nicht so viel RAM
Also mir ist ein CPU-Core lieber als mehr RAM oder so
Das finde ich eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee
Von den
Ubuntu, genau
Ubuntu, Ubuntu
Hätte noch jemand GameStop Aktien? GameStop ist an der Börse
Alter, was ist mit den GameStop Aktien los?
Äh, die sind heute auf 105 Euro rauf
Und jetzt auf 73 runter
Hä? Was haben die heute gemacht?
Was haben die heute gemacht?
Wo sind GameStop Stunks?
Was haben die gemacht?
Alter, was ist denn mit denen los?
Was ist denn mit denen los?
CacWade?
Warum? Was haben die denn gemacht?
Was für ein Reddit?
Guckt euch das mal an
Die waren... Alter, guck mal
3,54 Euro?
Kann man auf WallStreetBets nachlesen
Die Reddit-Dudes haben einfach irgendwas gekauft oder was?
Also es ist überhaupt nichts wichtiges passiert bei GameStop oder was?
Okay, okay
Okay, okay, der Fokus erklärt es
Okay, das ist reines Gambling gewesen, oder?
Also es hat mit GameStop gar nichts zu tun, quasi so richtig
Nice, perfekt, das Stunks-Game ist stark
So, aber genug Stunks
Wir erstellen jetzt unseren Server, sonst kommen wir zu nichts
So, drei Kerne, Netzwerk, SSH-Key, beste SSH-Key-Name
Den finde ich bestimmt sofort wieder, wenn ich ihn mal suche
Mal gucken, ob das Russendedos heute wieder am Start ist
Die kommenden Bots laufen schon an
Die laufen schon an
Es wird echt Zeit, dass mich Hetzer sponsert
Ich muss die anschreiben
So oft, wie ich das zeige
So, IP, zack
Zack, wir machen erst mal das ASCII-Quarium zu, ich glaube das läuft hier noch
Das zieht zu viel CPU-Resourcen
Hostinger habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
Kann ich irgendwas?
Preisvergleich, VPS-Hosting
Letztendlich ist die Hetzer-Cloud ja auch nichts anderes wie ein paar KVM-VMs
Da ist auch nichts
Heiß Cloud, weil es cool klingt, aber
Hetzer, weil die billig sind
Also, die Response-Zeit schockt mich schon
What the fuck, was ist das für eine Bedienung?
Haben die nicht einfach eine normale Auflistung?
Ok, was ist das?
1G? Eine CPU?
Ne
NetCup habe ich mir nur angeguckt
Ich checke es nicht
Wie viele Cores bekommt man hier?
Ein Kern, ok
Moment, das ist schon mal ein Euro teurer als Hetzer
Mach die Seite mal groß, ok, nice
Acht Kerne, acht
Ok, ne, da ist Hetzer immer noch günstiger
Und wie viel? 100 MBit? Hat er es nur?
Ne, warum soll ich das nehmen?
Bandbreite, acht, guck mal, bei Hetzer kriege ich mehr Kerne für weniger Geld
Mehr Bandbreite und mehr, also mehr Übertragungsbandbreite und mehr Netzwerkbandbreite
Warum soll ich das nehmen?
Also
Die Hetzer-Dinger sind einfach unschlachbar günstig
So, IP kopieren, zack
Ups
Sehr
Ah, eins, genau
Yes
Update
Du, du, du, du, du, du
Erst mal, erst mal, immer ein Update machen nachdem man einen Server installiert hat
Ist das Mario Kart oder ist das Platoon Musik?
Mario Kart
So, Upgrade
Erst mal, erst mal das Ding update, man weiß ja nie wie alt das ist
Letztendlich sind die Server bei Hetzer immer neu, die haben sogar einen eigenen Mirror was sie stehen
Dachte ich, aber anscheinend nicht
Was sind denn die Vorteil-Nachteile von den Githooks versus CI?
Die Githooks ist pro Repo, also das ist quasi in ein Repo gebunden und du managst das auch im Repo
Das ist eher was, wenn man selbst alleine an einem Projekt arbeitet
Du musst ja nach wie vor auch alle Dependencies und Gedöns installieren
Und
Es ist halt praktischer, wenn du mit mehreren Leuten dran arbeitest und vielleicht noch automatisierte Tests machen willst
Bevor du Code von den Leuten annimmst
Also zum Beispiel, wenn irgendwie einer einen Pull-Request aufmacht und du willst vorher wissen, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist, dass du das merged
Dann willst du vielleicht automatisch irgendwo
Ne, ne, ne, dann soll man Testinstallationen machen
Die gewisse Tests ausführt und dir dann ein Report liefert, ob das alles noch funktioniert
So, das ist mit der Variante, wie ich es jetzt mache, naja machbar, aber schön im Handling ist es nicht
Und wenn du GitHub Actions hast oder irgendein anderes CI-System, da kannst du zum Beispiel ein paar Jobs definieren
Der checkt dir das dann aus, der installiert das, lässt ein paar Tests laufen und poste dann in dem Pull-Request
So nach dem Motto alle Tests erfolgreich oder drei von zehn Tests fehlgeschlagen oder was auch immer
Und dann weißt du als Repo, Betreuer, Master, was auch immer
Dass der Typ gleich nochmal neu comitten, das funktioniert nicht
Und das ist vom Handling auch besser, wenn du beispielsweise irgendeinen, was weiß ich nenne
Irgendeine Support-Nachtschicht hast, die was deployen muss, weil das Tagshuber aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht geht
Und die gehen dann einfach da ins Webinterface und klicken zwei Knöp
Anstatt dass die irgendwelche Git-Commandos ausführen müssen
Aber im Prinzip ist ja CI auch nicht
Also im Kern auch nicht viel mehr als automatisch zu irgendeinem gewissen Ereignis Skripte ausführen
Wenn man sich mal die ursprüngliche Jenkins-Geschichte anguckt
Das war so eines der ersten Systeme in der Richtung
Mittlerweile ist das schon eine ganze Ecke weitergekommen als Jenkins
Wobei ich persönlich mag Jenkins immer noch
Jenkins war im Endeffekt ein Webfrontend, wo du zu bestimmten Ereignissen einfach Skripts ausgeführt hast
Also im Prinzip ist das alles kein großer Unterschied
Es kommt nur drauf an, wie fancy das gemacht ist
Da hoffst du glaube ich vergebens, weil die EHK ist nicht kompetent
Egal wie und wo
Shit wird installiert
Jedes Mal wenn ich das ausspreche, muss ich an so ein Premium Azubi denken
Das habe ich euch schon hundertmal erzählt
Was es heute gibt ist folgendes
Wir installieren uns erstmal einen Hetzner Server mit zehn Public IPs und machen ein Proxy drauf
Allerdings nicht Public, also den dürft ihr nicht verwenden
Sonst habe ich gleich die 30 Milliarden Torrents, wobei die Torrents geht nicht über den Squid
Sonst habe ich gleich irgendwelche China Dudes oder so am Start, die dürft ihr nicht drauf
Aber der Preis-Cham darf drauf
Und dann dockerisieren wir Preis-Cham und gucken, dass wir es automatisch mit einem Git push, deployen und refreshen können auf dem Server
Richtig, Mario, genau deswegen mag ich das auch
Ich mein kannst du bei GitHub Actions auch
Kannst du bei GitHub Actions auch
Aber es ist halt ein bisschen größerer Akt
Bei Jenkins hast du einfach, in den Fels hast du irgendwie Post Builds Script
Und dann pastest du den Bash rein und gut ist
Deswegen mag ich Jenkins
Ich bin eh mittlerweile
Also irgendwie so an dem Punkt angelangt, dass ich viele Oldschool-Dinger mag, weil die oftmals simpel sind
So der richtig krasse Cloud-Native-Enabler-Architekt
Um jetzt mal ein paar Passwörter zusammenzustecken in einen Topf, die nicht zusammenpassen
Der kommt ihm lebendig auf die Idee und sagt, wir machen einfach einen Post-Receive-Hook, um zu deployen
Nee, nee, nee, nee, also wenn das nicht über ein ordentliches CI-System geht mit irgendwie 30.000 Message-Cues dazwischen und sonstigen Sachen, dann ist das nicht cool genug
Das ist da nicht Cloud-Native genug
Man muss sich übertreiben, aber so ein paar Sachen für kleine Dinge, das hat alles eine Daseinsberechtigung
Aber für kleine Sachen ist es manchmal viel besser, man verwendet irgendwas Simples
Zum Beispiel den Jenkins oder eben den Githook
Oder wenn Nagios meinen, wenn es sein muss, wenn man keinen Bock hat auf Zappix und irgendwelche Big Brain, Prometheus, Grafana, Elk, was auch immer
Das tut es auch noch, auch wenn ich immer Shep angeguckt werde, wenn ich sage, ich mag Nagios, aber ich finde Nagios nicht schlecht
Man muss auch nicht alles verkontenerisieren, also wie gesagt, es gibt Leute, die starten heute einen Container, um erst einmal LS auszuführen, übertrieben gesagt
Das muss nicht sein
GitLab-CI habe ich nie richtig verwendet
Ich habe mir das mal angeguckt, als es neu war, und dann haben wir bei uns auf der Arbeit GitLab abgeschafft
Und dann hatte ich das nie wieder angeschaut
Also von den großen Public-CI-Systemen, ich kenne nur GitHub, also GitHub Actions, ein bisschen Travis
Dann, ich habe vergessen, wie das Atlassian-Ding heißt, war es Bamboo?
Das hat zumindest gesackt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß
War das Bamboo, BitBuget-Bamboo oder so? Kann das sein?
Das ging mir auf den Sack, da hatte ich nach 5 Stunden keinen Bock mehr drauf
Und Jenkins, ja
Jenkins habe ich eine ganze Weile, ich glaube, ich habe den ersten Jenkins bei uns in der Firma damals installiert
Und wir haben Server-Tests gemacht, also man muss ja nicht mal Software-Zeug damit machen, wir haben Server-Tests damit gemacht
Und Config-Updates
Und ein paar automatische Tests vorher
Bis dann irgendwie einer BigBrain auf die Idee gekommen ist, hat gemeint
Nein, nein, eigene solche Server und GitLab darf nicht mehr betrieben werden, weil wir machen jetzt für alle BitBuget
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, keck wait, aber das funktioniert doch so gut bei uns
So, und jetzt haben wir uns umgestellt auf das ganze Atlassian-Zeug
Und wenn du irgendwie einfach nur ein neues Häkchen haben willst, musst du dich erstmal an das Atlassian-Team wenden
Und dauert 3 Wochen bis irgendwas gemacht ist
Exzellent, exzellent
Ja, und jetzt haben wir übrigens wieder einen eigenen Jenkins
Nur dass ich mich um den nicht mehr kümmere
So, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich wollte Public-IPs auf den Server drauf machen, habe ich gesagt, Public-IPs auf den Server
Also, das geht, by the way, warum habe ich da eigentlich, ah, weil das ein anonymer Tab ist, haha, verstehe
Exzellent, exzellent
Dann machen wir jetzt einfach so, bam
Ich weiß nicht, was bei E3 Tabbing aktivieren war
E3 WM Tab
Kann ich mir immer nicht merken, den Shortcut
Na ja, Tabbed, Tabbed, CTRL E
Alt-Shift-T, ne, ne, ne
Warte mal, alt, doch
Ne, äh
Wow
Was ist Tabbed?
Ich gucke jetzt einfach mal meine
Achso, da habe ich kein E3-Config drauf
Äh, Switch
What the fuck, das habe ich glaube ich gar nicht belegt, weil ich das nie verwende
Aber jetzt bräuchte ich es mal
Ne, das habe ich nicht belegt
0W
Ne, doch hier, da, Tiling
Ne, Floating, Toggle Mode
Warte mal, Base, da habe ich schon
Mod
Mod-Space, ne, hat's
Ach, hier ist es doch, da steht's doch
Tabbed, Stacking, Stacking ist auch okay
Stacking, Mod, Mod-S
Ah, das habe ich gesucht
Max, ich habe zu meinem Prof gerade 0 gesagt, so gehört sich das
Ich mein, du hättest auch 0W sagen können, da ist 0 doch die bessere Alternative
0W wäre natürlich noch besser gewesen
Aber, aber ansonsten ist das doch ziemlich
So, wunderbar, jetzt haben wir den Kram hier
Ich wollte Public-IPs haben, genau, Public-IPs
Also, bei Hetzer geht das folgendermaßen
Jeder Server kriegt standardmäßig eine IP
Die man nicht ändern kann
Das ist mir aufgefallen
Ich glaube, da geht nur über Support-Ticket die IP ändern oder einen neuen Server erstellen
Und aus Snapshots restoren, was ich nicht verstehe
Warum Hetzer nicht einfach hier einen Button hinmacht für neue DHCP-Zuweisungen
Verstehe ich nicht
Aber okay
So, wir adden jetzt neue IPs, also
Neue IP, wir brauchen 10 IPs, eine haben wir schon, also
Äh, eins
Bigpray-Name, übrigens
Wir machen uns mal, wir machen uns mal einen, einen Skript
Äh
Und kopieren diesen ganzen Krempel mal rein
Dass ich das dann nicht von Hand machen muss
Ich, ich, ich lege keine Netplan-Config an, ich hasse Netplan
Ich mag Ubuntu-Server, aber Netplan geht mir so auf den Sack
Netplan ist die neue, wer das nicht kennt
Netplan ist die neue Variante, wie man IPs in Ubuntu konfiguriert
Früher, unter Ubuntu beziehungsweise Debian
Bist du einfach Network, Interfaces gegangen
Und hast da den Kram reingeschrieben
Aber die haben sich bei Ubuntu gedacht
Nein
Das ist zu einfach
Das wollen wir nicht
Wir müssen jetzt Yammel-Konfiguration machen
Jetzt hast du sowas hier
Netplan
Jetzt hast du sowas
What the fuck
Also was ist einfacher
So eine, so eine hässliche Yammel-Datei
Oder einfach die IPs untereinander schreiben
Deswegen, ich schlag mich damit jetzt einfach gar nicht rum
Äh, ich kopier mir das jetzt einfach alles in der Datei und gut ist
Das ist der Ubuntu-Jubuntu-Way
Ja, das muss man nachinstellen
Aber ganz ehrlich, für den Test hier
Ich paste mir einfach die ganzen Commands hier rein und gut ist
Also
So, eins, zwei IPs
Drei IPs
Also übrigens, eine IP kostet 1,19 Euro im Monat
Das bedeutet
Meine Serverkosten werden schon mal um
Um 10,71 Euro teurer im Monat
Not stonks, ja
Übrigens, das ist auch eine schöne Variante
Wenn sich irgendwie einer tunneln will
Sei es aus der Arbeit raus tunneln
Was man natürlich je nach Policy nicht darf
Deswegen will ich das jetzt auch keinem empfehlen
Oder wenn er einen Dual-Stack-Lite hat
Wenn er noch einen richtigen
Wenn er eine echte Public IPv4-Adresse haben will
Mit Dual-Stack-Lite
Kann er sich auch dahin tunneln
Dann hast du quasi Tunnel
Tunnel im Dual-Stack-Lite-Tunnel
Das ist dann besonders exzellent für die Performance
Aber letztendlich unter der Haube
Wahrscheinlich wirst du es gar nicht merken, großartig
Dafür hast du dann eine echte IPv4-Adresse
Und kannst dann Minecraft bei dir daheim spielen
Mit deinen Kollegen
So, sieben IPs haben wir
Eine brauchen wir
Nee, zwei brauchen wir noch
Zack
Copy
Eine noch, gif
Wie viel kostet eine IPv6?
Wahrscheinlich gar nichts
Oh, doch
Okay
Naja, es ist ja nicht nur die IP, die du hier bezahlst
Was du hier eigentlich bezahlst
Ist, dass du die IP an jeden Server
Attachen kannst, den du willst
Das ist das eigentliche Feature
IPs hast du selbst
Genau, du hast nämlich schon ein
Slash64-Netz auf deinem Server drauf
Also du kannst da eigentlich IP-Adressen verwenden
Soviel du lustig bist
Was diese Floating-IPs ausmacht ist
Ich könnte mir jetzt einen zweiten Server
Also zum Beispiel, wofür das da ist
Stell euch mal vor, ihr habt einen Server
Mit einer Public-IP
Und ein Service drauf ist
Und ihr wollt den OnTheFly upgraden
Dann macht ihr einen Snapshot
Einen neuen Server mit mehr Kern, mehr RAM
Restore den Snapshot
Startet darauf alles
Und dann hängt ihr die Floating-IP
Von einem Server an den anderen dran
Man sieht es nach außen hin so aus
Als ist das immer noch der gleiche Server
Die Wirklichkeit hinten dran kommt auf den anderen raus
Aber es ist eine gute Möglichkeit
Um mehr IPs zu bekommen
So, jetzt haben wir unsere IPs am Start
Dann werden wir die mal kurz
Ups, vielleicht soll ich mal was umdrehen
Nein!
6, IP
Dann werden wir die IPs auf unserem Server anlegen
Und wir sehen, wir haben massig Public-IPs
Hier, mit dem zusammen 10
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 Public-IPs
Exquisite
Falls du schon beantwortet hast
Deine Meinung zum Raspberry Pi Pico
Ich finde es nicht sonderlich sinnvoll
Weil ich für fast alle Sachen, die ich daheim zum Basteln brauche
Also einen WLAN auf dem Ding brauche
Ich meine, vielleicht ist das was für irgendwelche Modellflieger oder so
Die ja gerne rumbasteln mit teilweise noch Arduino
Aber ganz ehrlich
Ich verstehe die Anwendung, die da sein soll
Ich verstehe die Anwendung, die Daseinsberechtigung
Nur so zum Teil von dem Pi Pico
Weil ich kann einfach einen ESP32 nehmen
Da habe ich WLAN dabei
Kostet ungefähr genau das gleiche
Und kann sogar noch mehr
Und ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein Ticken schneller
Ist wahrscheinlich auch strumsparender im Deep Sleep
Keine Ahnung wo das Sinn da war
Ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung von dem Raspberry Pi Pico nicht so richtig
Wenn ich ehrlich bin
So, haben wir schon geupdatet?
Leute, haben wir schon rebooted nachdem wir Kernelupdate gemacht haben?
Ich weiß es nicht
Aber wir machen jetzt erstmal die Firewall an
Nicht dass dann irgendjemand von außen wirklich den Proxy verwendet
Das wollen wir ja natürlich nicht
So, erstmal Firewall anmachen
Default, Deny, alle Sachen
UFW
Enable
Yes, haben wir alles richtig
Yes, wir sind nicht rausgeflogen
Alles, wir haben jetzt alles richtig gemacht
Dann machen wir gleich noch docker
Config für die Firewall rein
Total easy, den Kram hier copypasten
GitHub, ungefragt wie man das so macht
Einfach immer blind Sachen von GitHub copypasten
So machen das die Profis auch, sie da jetzt ja
So, äh, das ist übrigens die falsche Datei
Was ich da mache, kann ich dir gleich zeigen
Ups
Set, Paste
Wenn ihr ein Wim-Probleme habt beim Einfügen, macht vorher Set, Paste
Dann funktioniert der Kram auch
Wow, MonkaS, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Was wir heute machen ist folgendes
Aktuell installiere ich einen Hetznasein mit 10 Public IPs und einem Proxy drauf
Ähm, dass mein Preischamp unterschiedliche IPs zum Crawlen verwendet und ich nicht gesperrt werde
Oder nicht so schnell gesperrt werde
So, ähm
Dann verdockerisieren wir den Preischamp
Und machen automatisches Neustarten bei einem Gitpush
Lernen vom Profi, so sieht's aus
Und Stack Overflow, das sind zwei Sachen
Und auch ganz, was auch immer richtig gut ist
Ist Curl, Bloop, Punkt, äh, Bloop
Und dann natürlich nach
Äh, äh, nach Bash
Oder noch besser nach Sudo Bash
So, so machen das die wahren Profis
Ja, was bedeutet docker?
Docker ist ein Frontend für Linux Container
Linux Container ist im Prinzip nichts anderes
Wie ein Gesandboxter Prozess
Ich bin eh der Meinung, die Leute sollten zu Linux Container sagen, dass es ein Sandbox Prozess ist
Und weniger
Es ist so wie eine VM
Aber doch keine richtige VM
Das verwirrste die Leute doch
Nein, das ist überhaupt keine VM
Also Docker hat mit VMs nichts zu tun
Docker ist ein Gesandboxter Prozess
So ein bisschen sowas wie Dings, ähm
Ach, wie hieß der Kram früher?
Äh, es gab doch schon mal sowas ähnliches, was nie ein Kernel geschafft hat
Nee, nicht LXT, LXT ist ja im Prinzip das gleiche
Und, also die Kernelfunktionen sind die gleich
Wie hieß denn der Kram, der es nie in den Kerneln geschafft hat?
Ähm, das, das, das uralt Container
OpenVZ, genau, OpenVZ
OpenVZ mein ich, genau, das hat es nie in den Kerneln geschafft
Das ist ein bisschen in die gleiche Richtung
So, äh, haben wir schon restarted?
Ich glaube nicht, ich restarte mal
Nach dem Update, glaube haben wir nur ich restarted
Warum ist mein Darkreader nicht an?
MonkaS
Äh, äh, wie erlaubt man nochmal?
Extensions, Darkreader
Manage
Allow
Ah, yes
Gleich viel besser, viel besser
Hält ja keiner aus
Der Preischamp, den müssen wir jetzt einfach mal starten
Weil es geht und auch in Darkmount setzen, so ist das gut
Exzellent
So
Wunderbar
So, jetzt haben wir neu gestartet
Beide, weil du denkst, das ist ein MikroTik
Leute, ich hab mir einen MikroTik, ich hab mir einen neuen MikroTik-Switch bestellt
Aber nehme ich den hier
Äh, den, den stelle ich euch in einem der nächsten Videos mal vor
Weil ich mir gedacht habe
Es fragen mich immer wieder Leute, Max, was empfiehlst du
So an, an Hutern und Anbieter
Und ich habe mir gedacht, ich habe mir gedacht
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich habe mir gedacht, ich habe mir gedacht
Ich habe mir gedacht, wenn du einen MikroTik-Speгу
An Routern und an Switchen
Und sonst was, so für daheim, wenn man ein bisschen mehr machen will
Den da, ich habe ihn selbst noch nicht
Den will ich mal ausprobieren
Jetzt benutze ich doch den Server eh nicht dafür
Das jetzt zum ausprobieren
Den da, das Ding ist richtig
Geil, guckt euch das mal an
Kostet 85 Euro zur Zeit
85 Euro muss man sich mal vorstellen
Das ist massiv billig
85 Euro
Du bekommst
10g 8 mal 1g und und ich glaube dual power supply für 85 euro
Ich weiß gar nicht was mit dem mikrotik los ist was
Ja ok das ist switch os da stimmt das ist kein router os
Aber die meisten leute sind mit inklusive mir ja sind eh mit router os überfordert und die wie lang config die die wie lang config für
switch os router os auch komplett verkackt
Also der ist wirklich nice und wenn ihr zwei ports nicht reichen dann kombinierst du den einfach mit einem
Mikrotik c
Ach du scheiße 4
4 s plus
Der da
Dann kombinierst du den einfach mit so einem der kost gibt es den eigentlich auch in nur switch variante
Dann kombinierst du den nämlich einfach mit so einem der kostet dann noch mal 120
Der kostet noch mal 109 euro oder 110 euro obendrauf und dann hast du in kombination was richtig nice ist dann hast du so ziemlich
die günstigste variante von
Gigabit port und naja vier
Vier sfp plus port so kannst du machen
Aber du kannst auch genau du kannst auch einfach einholen mit mehr mit mehr ports haben die ja auch
Ich habe beide da ich werde ja mal auch gleich zusammen stöpseln am besten ist ihr kauft auch klar
Ihr kauft euch gleich noch ein paar direkt attach kabel dabei weil die meisten leute haben daheim also sowas hier in der richtung
Weil die meisten leute haben daheim eh keine großartigen strecken die wollen dann von ihrem serverraum zwei meter weg zu ihrem rechner
Und da ist mit so einem attach kabel einfach viel besser da bezahlst du bei ebay teilweise 10 10 10 euro für
Kannst die dinger besser für plus verbinden
Und du brauchst kein modul und kein kupfer adapter und sonst was einfach
Geht glaube ich maximal bis fünf meter oder so aber das reicht den meisten leuten
Die meisten leuten wollen 10g nicht im ganzen haus verteilen
Den unify den den den hab ich daheim ne ich hab ich hab es ich hab ich hab kein uni ich hab kein unify 16 xg
Ich hab nen edge switch 16 xg ist aber im prinzip die gleiche kiste
Die habe ich mir damals gekauft für knapp 550 euro weil das vor vor drei jahren so eines der besten sachen für 10g war
Heute wird ich mir den mikrotek kaufen
Das ist auch eine router da ist teurer switch switch router kombi ding der ist auch teurer geworden als er am anfang war
auch teurer geworden als er am anfang war
Ist das 10g internet oder 10g daten
was
Es gibt kein 10g es gibt nur 10g daten das das ist ein 10 gigabit link
das heißt wenn du da ein kabel rein steckst und zwei
Geräte aneinander stöpselst dann sünden die mit dem port 10 mit 10 gigabit mit dem port
Was du dann darüber machst ist egal
Du kannst da auch dein internet rüber laufen lassen aber der internet wird natürlich dadurch nicht schneller
Weil dadurch dein ablink zum provider das limitierende ist wenn du einfach nur 10g switch daheim hinstellen könntest und dann provider wäre auf einmal
10g dann hätte ich auch schon 10g
Ja die dinge habe ich auch schon letztens gesehen mit wie den habe ich auch letzten schon gesehen
Wobei ich bin bei den dinger nicht sicher bin was stromverbrauch und lautstärke angeht hat natürlich eine super die super bewertung
Also keine ahnung was was da an stromverbrauch und lautstärke angeht der ist auch noch passiv der ist auch noch komplett silent
So jetzt machen wir den kram erstmal wieder zu ich will gar nicht mehr durchbauen mit so vielen tabs
Jetzt habe ich tabs hier und tabs da
Da steige ich gar nicht mehr durch
Der ist passiv ich kann mich noch daran erinnern vor ein paar jahren auf youtube war das eine beleidigung wenn einer gesagt hat sei nicht so passiv
Schmonack es
Ich weiß vielleicht ist es dass in manchen kreisen heute immer noch so wir müssen erst mal weitermachen also wir haben jetzt einen server mit
Einer public ip und jetzt ein server mit zehn public ips excellent so wir machen mal kurz den port scan und gucken wir ob da auch alles schön dicht ist
ssh
nmap weil ich habe keinen bock dass irgendwelche russen mein comrades meinen proxy gleich verwenden
Das ist nur für localhost gedacht nicht für irgendwelche illegalen dinger. Ah hetzner plockt alles klar
Oh die reshop musik
Okay, ssh ist auf das ist okay ssh darf aufsteigen excellent ssh
Es die andern ips auch mal testen einmal eine runde port scan
Also ideen für heimautomatisierung mit nfc tags
Ich habe ja ich habe letztens. Ja schon. Auf twitter was gepost wie ich das gemacht habe
Ich schalte zum beispiel meine heizung im baden an und aus ich setze mich aufs klo her halte das smartphone an so einen korp mit dem nfc tag
dann geht der lüfter an
Lüfte an
Beispiel ich habe im schlafzimmer nehmen wir mal ein bettmann tag
Das macht noch nicht alles was ich was ich will zum beispiel rollen runter und sowas weil das liegt an den rollers
Der macht aber zum beispiel schon licht dimmen und macht es dann aus und so was schon ganz ganz nice
So ok also jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir einen server mit zehn mit zehn ips
Ich brauche übrigens noch mal einen service kennt jemand einen guten service das muss ich jetzt auf dem zweiten
rechner suchen der meine public ip
anzeigt
mit der ich raus gehe
Gv4 ap address public
If konf if konfig punkt co
Da hänge ich im cloudflare drin
Ah exquisite ich habe aber was anderes gerade gefunden
Ich habe gerade was anderes gefunden mal gucken ob das auch funktioniert
Jawohl ok damit kann ich nämlich testen ob der wirklich balanced über die über die verschiedenen externen ips
Da müssen wir uns erstmal ein kleines script basteln was ist hier los
weil du du das da
Und dann
Aber noch ein echt hinten dran es lieb eins dann so aktuell geht er immer über die gleiche ip raus
Lieg oh fuck meine hetzen ip ist liegt wie gesagt die russischen botnetze laufen schon warm ich höre ich höre sie schon im hintergrund
Leute ich höre schon in fünf in fünf minuten sind sie da
Dann muss ich den server löschen in euren legen
Ok also wir sehen das ist immer die gleiche public ip so und jetzt installieren wir in squid
Und dann kommt squid konf squid
mit
tippenfisch ist am start hast du noch probleme seit cloudflare nö
Nope nur dass ich selbst jetzt nicht mehr drauf kommen
mit meinem monitor in zeug weil ich es noch nicht umgestellt habe
also squid konfig
Das das wichtigste was man bei das squid konfig erst mal machen muss ist folgendes also ihr seht wie fett die default squid konfig ist
Seht ihr das die ist lang die ist
8586 zeilen lang mit mit comments das wichtigste was man mit der default squid konfig machen muss ist das hier
Dann muss ich erst mal löschen
So und dann geht man bei google und sagt squid outgoing ip randomize
Und dann sucht man sich den stack overflow oder server fault oder irgendwas raus wo drin steht wie das geht
Ich weiß dass es geht ich habe keine ahnung wie so so scheint es zu funktionieren guck mal her
Exzellent
Das ist das was man unter anderem auch stack overflow driven programming oder in dem fall
server fault driven server administrating nennt
So und jetzt pasen wir das einfach rein und hoffen dass das stimmt aber da müssen wir jetzt unsere ips reinschreiben sonst klappt es nicht
Moment wir müssen da unsere ips reinschreiben
Sonst funzt es nicht
So
Gibt es irgendeine vim magic wie wir das machen können change ups
Hallo
Oh es hat geleckt und botnetze sind schon am start alter
So nimmst du den sandwich mode dass ich nicht zwei verschiedene fenster permanent hier im nebeneinander auf hab
Change tcp
Outgoing
address so und jetzt von der idee her könnte ich doch
Ah yes vim logik so und jetzt machen wir noch mehr vim magic achtung störnchen
Zack zack zack zack zack zack
Und jetzt ach so na gut das mit dem random funktioniert nicht
Das funktioniert soll ich euch erzählen wie ich das gemacht habe das ganz einfach also
Also ich mache noch mal rückgängig ich mache noch mal rückgängig
Ups
Also ich mache noch mal rückgängig
Ich habe das markiert was ich was ich löschen will dann drücke ich c
Dann schreibe ich das hin was ich machen will
outgoing
address so
Und dadurch dass das ist ein eine
Edit operation und wenn man jetzt auf die nächste zeile geht und den punkt drückt dann
Wiederholt vim die letzte
Edit operation so und wenn man auf das sudo geht und drückt störnchen
Dann lädt er sudo in die search history und dann kann ich mit n
Zwischen den sudo vorkommnissen hin und zurückspringen das heißt ich drücke n
Für zum nächsten sudo springen
Punkt für letzte edit operation und dann
Man könnte übrigens auch search und replace machen wir kommen doch gleich heraus
Mit sicherheit geht es noch einfacher
so also
Jetzt müssen wir gucken wir das man das
Das das könnte also
Wir können jetzt erstmal die graben hier löschen
Und jetzt
Jetzt gehen wir dahin
Sagen markieren das
Sagen i leerzeichen random escape beim jetzt hatte überall random eingefügt
Wobei wir machen das anders
Und das problem ist wir hätten wir hätten wir hätten wir hätten es schon wir hätten es schon längst wir hätten es schon längst copy pasted aber
Wir müssen wim magic machen
also random
zwei
So und jetzt kommt wim magic guckt mal
Ja
Zwar total sinnlos wir hätten schneller copy pasted aber immerhin immerhin
Oh was ist meine richtige aber eine richtige public ip was geht hier ab also wenn du wissen willst was wir waren wir machen folgendes
Aktuell sammeln in der netzen surfer installiert mit zehn public ips
Und da machen wir jetzt ein proxy drauf den ich dann mit meiner anwendung verwenden kann um
Ins internet also mit um mit unterschiedliche absender ip ins internet zu gehen und dinge abzufragen so dass ich nicht so schnell geploggt werde
Warte manne wie geht das warum ist das da unten warum hat es da unten kein random dahinter
Und warum hat es kein random dahinter alles andere hat random
Wir hinterfragen stack auf das ist auch eine sache die man lernen muss
Wir akzeptieren einfach das deck overflow schlauer ist als wir
Und schon hat man weniger probleme
Einfach davon ausgehen stack overflow ist schlauer
Einfach copy pasten wie gesagt heute ist ja das thema heute ist ja lernen vom profi
Und da war das jetzt
So mal gucken und und auch eine ganz wichtige sache nein ich könnte nicht den proxy verwendet was ich jetzt geploggt habe eine ganz wichtige sache ist erst mal
config speichern und service neu starten und gucken ob es geht
Wenn es nämlich geht ist die chance dass es funk richtig ist und das ist auch ein
Zauber den
die konfig datei meckert
Bei der ich hoffe die meisten leute verstehen dass ich das alles nicht ganz ernst meine das muss man immer noch dabei sagen weil
Manche leute sind halt nicht gesappt und dementsprechend zu lau das zu verstehen
So und jetzt starten wir einfach mal den squid und gucken ob es funktioniert list nicht licht was mal
Ich stelle status squid. Oh er geht nicht, komm squid ist kaputt also ist die konfig datei wahrscheinlich kaputt
Warum ist das warum ist squid
gedingst
Das
Fuck squid minus k
Aha, ach du scheiße squid
Command check konfig es gab so ein konfig überprüfungs ding
Wie geht das minus k minus k pass
Was kann ich doch kein menschen merken so unsere konfig datei ist
prinzipiell
ok
Kann das sein weil ich kein port angegeben habe ok minimal squid konfig
Minimum squid konfig excellent ah das ist minimal alles klar erst mal 50 teilen was was brauchen wir denn hier gibt so was wie listen
LTP port
LTP ok das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich das kann und das wird wahrscheinlich ohne port nicht funktionieren
So und dann brauchen wir noch irgendwas
Haben wir dann irgendwie sowas wie wie lau oder sowas dass man auch drauf zugreifen kann lau
Gab es nicht sowas wie lau all oder sowas beim squid ist schon ich mache nicht ich mache nicht oft
Squid konfig das ist der aller kleinste server den es gerade gibt htx halb den den meine ich den das brauchen wir
Die IPs kostet 1 19 pro IP
Das ist der aller billigste kleinste ah ne stimmt nicht drei drei kernserver ist das wir haben doch nicht den billigsten genommen
so start squid
Easy funktioniert perfekt so und jetzt ganz wichtig erst mal gucken ob meine firewall regel richtig sind nicht dass ich ein proxy ins internet stelle das ist keine allzu gute idee
Nein mach ich nicht na kann man auch überprüfen
Teller auf port 3 2 8 hier kommt nix
Oder oder
Chat vielleicht habe ich mich auch vertan und ihr seid schon drin
Ich war einfach zu langsam
Wieso Teller
Wieso nicht Teller? Tochend läuft schon
Teller guckt kann man einfach gucken man kann auch netket nehmen oder irgendwas. Ja dem Teller
Teller kannst du gucken ob der port offen ist ob der tcp port auf ist wenn du zum beispiel Teller macht auf
google punkt die 80 dann verbindet das sich und du kannst dann auch harte tp
von hand machen wenn man weiß wie das ausschaut dann antwortet google das war habt ihr schon mal harte tp von hand gemacht
Also jetzt läuft das ganze soll jetzt müssen wir gucken ob das auch funktioniert
Ich die bagge kein proxy ich benutze ein funktionierenden proxy easy
Ihr seid ja ihr seid chat ihr seid so vertrauenswürdig dass ihr nie was machen würdet mit einem öffentlichen proxys aber im internet
Proxys aber im internet
Das tornaut ja klar das bestimmt schon drauf ich sehe schon kommen
Die cia ist sicherlich auch schon in alle
Die cia die israelis der bundesnachrichtigens alle sind am start
Alle auf meinem hetsa-server also
Wo sie man sieht hier also das geht noch nicht dass es über den proxy balanced wird alles
Und warum geht das nicht
Also ich habe keine ahnung ob es überhaupt funktioniert aber es kann auch nicht funktionieren
Köln verwendet starrmäßig kein proxy was willst du damit machen ich habe eine seite die
Preise anzeigt von aktueller hardware und im hintergrund ruft die halt den status ab
Und seiten wie amazon zum beispiel oder da wobei amazon geht eigentlich
Es gibt ein paar seiten die mögen das nicht wenn man zu oft anfragt
Und ich habe extra auch schon runter gedreht ich will ja nicht den osn oder so also ich habe es jetzt so eingestellt dass da
Jeden shop nur alle eins bis zwei minuten anfragt also man request alle eins bis zwei minuten ist jetzt nicht das problem
Aber manche haben mal dedos protection und alle möglichen dinge und dann hängste manchmal eine halbe stunde in irgendeiner protection drin und kann es nicht weiter preise abfragen
Dementsprechend mache ich jetzt einfach zehn public alpies und balance über die public alpies und dann ist die chance dass ich da irgendwie
In, irgendeinem capture hängen bleiben geringer
Und probieren zumindest aus ob das zu ist so also wir müssen jetzt köln erst mal dazu überreden dass der unsere public alpies verwendet das kann
Man folgendermaßen export http proxy
Localhost 3 2 8 und jetzt sagt man karl der soll den squirt verwenden
Packt doch ein meiner in die preis gem site
So gute idee es fällt bestimmt keinem auf wenn er auf die seite geht dass er auf einmal 100 prozent cpu last hat
Exquisite idee
Funktioniert guckt hier meine karl request gehen alle über unterschiedliche ip's raus
Sehr gut
Die abfragen über leute die den preis champ besuchen das geht nicht das kann man das ist ja eines der security features von browser
beziehungsweise webserver so ein bisschen in kombination dass wenn ich
Nicht der server bin von dem die webseite ausgeliefert wurde dann kann ich nicht so ohne weiteres auf der webseite
Bevor ich die webseite ausgeliefert habe
Dann kann ich nicht so ohne weiteres auf der webseite ausgeliefert werden
Wenn ich nicht der server bin von dem die webseite ausgeliefert wurde dann kann ich nicht so ohne weiteres auf den anderen server
Zugreifen der das nicht will
Das ist schon absichtlich so
Preis champ elektron ab ich habe mir überlebt ich werde übrigens ich werde ich werde
Ich mache wahrscheinlich echte ios app wenn das alles funktioniert und zwar ich habe gestern ein video gesehen über
ionic
Capacitor dann ist mir aufgefallen das hat auch jemand letztens im stream gepostet da konnte ich bloß und nichts mit anfangen
Ich habe ein video dazu gesehen
Und da kann man auf knopfdruck
Was das das kostet was ne das ist das ist umsonst
Ernsthaft oder du meinst in den app store in den app store kostet 200
Na ja youtube money regelt und da kannst du nämlich auf knopfdruck
Ios apps android app gut pwmach ich selbst und jetzt kommt desktop elektron apps erzeugen
Ihr wolltet sicherlich den preis champ schon allemal als desktop elektron app verwenden
Affiliate money regeln die haben alle kein affiliate oder alternate
haben die sowas
Alternate partnerprogramm
Das 100 partnerprogramme das ist doch das ist doch tibet oder
Das ist doch tibet das das die alternat wird doch nicht immer so eine bescheuerte seiten partnerprogramm machen
Ne ist kein scam doch stimmts gam
Hä aber
Warum machen die sowieso eine kacke seite das ist das ist scam das ist übelst gar maß
Guckt euch das mal an
Die hätten die hätten garantiert die hätten garantiert auf ihrer eigenen seite was stehen
Quatsch das gibt es nicht das ist die hätten garantiert was wir ihre seite was steh moment
Wo
Moment.
Wow!
...
What?
Jetzt.
Warum machen die das über irgendwelche komischen Scammer Seiten?
Okay, äh, äh, das ist Firefox.
Ich mach's mal im Chrome auf, vielleicht geht's dem Chrome besser.
...
Warum ist die Seite so im Arsch?
Okay, das ist eine Seite, die geht bestimmt nur unter Windows.
...
Was ist denn mit Alternate grad los, ist total kaputt?
Welfil kann man grad nicht spielen, das ist übelst grade am rumhacken bei Venice.
Warum ist das so kaputt?
Was?
Das Funst?
Hä?
Okay, versteh ich nicht.
Die, die Logik, äh, Logik leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Na gut, was auch immer.
...
Haben Sie schon was von Arvin gehört? Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich will keinen Banner auf die Seite.
Das kommt als Refling hin.
Beast Mode, dankeschön für den Sub.
Äh, OSX in AVM ist auch gar nicht so einfach.
Also die einfachste Variante ist tatsächlich das hier, GitHub, Mac OS, Virtual Box.
Das da.
Das führst du einfach aus und es funktioniert, wenn es dich nicht stört, dass du Virtual Box verwendest.
Das werd ich übrigens auch machen, weil ich werd meine App irgendwie signen müssen.
Und das geht ja nur, weil Apple sich gedacht hat, niemand entwickelt iOS Apps unter, garantiert unter einem anderen Betriebssystem als Mac.
Braucht man zwingend Mac und Xcode, um den Scheiß zu signen, ne?
Das ist halt Apple-Logik.
Was ist das für ein komisches Partnerprogramm?
Nice, hat Mindfactory auch so was?
Partnerprogramm.
Bam, die haben alles Partnerprogramme.
Oh, ex, exellent, exellent.
Da mach ich, da mach ich, da mach ich alles.
Da mach ich, da mach ich überall, da mach ich überall Partnerprogramm, mach die Reflinks rein.
Beste.
Stonks gibts dann.
Richtig Stonks.
Was, warte mal, was hab ich denn sonst noch da für Dinger drinne?
PC King.
Hat PC King auch so was?
Chris Packaging Shop.
Ne, das ist, äh, was, was?
Anderes.
Nice.
Da mach ich überall Affiliate-Stells an Start, wo es geht, lull.
Easy Money.
So, also.
Weiter gehts.
Also, unser Squid funktioniert wunderbar.
Der Test war schon mal erfolgreich.
Also, können wir sagen, Punkt eins.
Irgendjemand hat gesagt, wir machen ein Programmier-Stream.
Wir machen auch gar keinen Programmier-Stream heute.
Heute machen wir einen richtigen Hacker-Man-Stream.
Also, das funktioniert.
Das haben wir schon mal abgehakt.
So, wir brauchen jetzt, das geht nicht alles.
Wir brauchen einen Emoji für den, für den Häkchen.
Okay, Sign.
Oh ne, das darf man nicht mehr verwenden, Leute.
Kritisch, kritisch, das darf man nicht mehr verwenden.
Das ist Monka Toss mittlerweile.
Gabs nicht, gab es nicht nen Häkchen?
Ah ja, hier.
Exzellent, den da.
Jawoll, so.
Beste, beste To-To-Liste aller Zeiten.
So, haben wir abgehakt.
Checkmark, genau.
Warum?
Also, weil das heute,
für Leute, die den Hintergrund nicht kennen,
Kruper, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Weil die Leute low-brain sind, um ehrlich zu sein.
Was machst du da?
Ich hab gerade einen Server installiert,
mit 10 Public IPs und einem Proxy,
der jetzt meine Anfragen random verteilt
über die Public IPs.
Also,
das kommt daher.
Irgendjemand ist öfter, also,
in dem Fall ist es Fortnite gewesen,
ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
in die Welt zu setzen, dass Okay Hand
ein rassistisches
Hasssymbol ist.
So, und nachdem die Amis
nicht allzu helle sind, was das anbelangt,
haben dann mit der Zeit
tatsächlich Medien
angefangen, das aufzugreifen.
Und so wurde Pepe
der Frosch und das Okay-Sign
irgendwann zu einem
rassistischen Hate-Speech-
Hasssymbol, was auch immer.
Das ging dann so weit,
dass echte rassistische
Gruppierungen
angefangen haben, dieses Symbol zu machen.
Also, ich glaube, das war eines der
Trolls von 4chan,
wo sie sich im Nachhinein gewünscht haben,
dass er nicht so erfolgreich gewesen.
Die haben sich halt gedacht, wir trollen die Leute
ein bisschen so dumm, kann keiner sein,
aber die haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass die Leute wirklich
so dumm sein können.
Deswegen ist Pepe, ist auch, deswegen ist das
ja auch ein Nazi-Hasssymbol.
Weil die Leute
einfach dumm sind.
Dieses Zeichen hat zigtausend Bedeutungen
gemacht, das kann alles Mögliche sein.
Alter, nein, das ist so.
Die Leute sind einfach hängen geblieben.
So, jetzt haben wir das geschafft.
Also, Punkt Nummer 1, erfolgreich
erledigt und das Ganze nach
1 Stunde 12.
Gut, ich habe gesagt, wir brauchen eine Viertel-Stunde,
aber ihr kennt mich.
Also, wenn ich sage, eine Viertel-Stunde
und wir brauchen eine Stunde 15,
dann ist das schon ziemlich, ziemlich nah dran,
oder?
Der neue Pokchamp, Grip
war der beste Pokchamp.
Grip war, das war
der einzige Pokchamp, den ich bisher, der mir
bisher gefallen hat.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin immer damit,
sie hätten einfach den Original-Pokchamp
lassen sollen, weil sich niemand dafür
interessiert hat, was das für ein Typ ist.
Ja, aber Semper, das ist ein
Better-Twitch-TV-Emote. Also, machen wir mal weiter.
Docker-File für den Preis-Champ.
So, jetzt wird
der DevOps-Modus hochgefahren.
Boomer-Modus deaktiviert, DevOps-Modus
aktiviert.
Nachdem das mit dem Public-IP und dem
Squid jetzt ja funktioniert,
kann ich den Server einfach mal rebooten
und dann sind wieder alle IPs weg.
Beste Taktik,
um alle IPs runterzukriegen, einfach
rebooten.
Und irgendwann ist er wieder da.
Sollte zumindest irgendwann wieder da sein.
Ha, da ist er wieder!
Boah, er funzt noch im Internet
und die IPs sind weg.
Sehr gut. So, jetzt können wir folgendes
machen. Wir installieren uns ein
und dann können wir die IPs
wieder wegladen.
So, jetzt können wir die IPs
So, jetzt können wir die IPs wieder
wegladen.
So, jetzt können wir folgendes machen.
Wir installieren uns eine Runde Docker
und Docker Compose.
Äh,
Composer ist Composer,
nicht PHP.
Ja,
ich meine, das, guckt euch das Logo
an und guckt euch an, für was das
für eine Framework ist. Also,
das ist nicht, das ist nicht zufällig,
beides schlecht.
Das ist
echt so ein Logo für Arme.
So, nachdem wir natürlich auch keine Docker
Runtime Exposen wollen, haben wir vorher
die ganzen, äh, UWF-Regeln
angepasst mit diesem Skript. Also sprich,
selbst wenn ich jetzt einen
Portscan mache,
mein Docker
ist standardmäßig eh nicht Exposed.
Hoffentlich mal zumindest, weiß ich es
gar nicht. Ich mache immer, ich mache immer die
Firewall an.
Nee, ich glaube, ich stelle mich nicht Exposed.
Connection Refused, ey, das stimmt, ich habe
echt schon bange Minuten gehabt mit Connection
Refused-Fehlermeldung.
Okay, außer SSH ist nichts offen auf dem Server.
Docker PS. So, also, was ich mir
jetzt gedacht habe, was wir machen, ist folgendes.
Ähm,
also, wir bauen jetzt erstmal
ein Docker-File für Preisschamp.
Gucken wir, ob das
lokal funktioniert.
Dann bauen wir einen Docker-Compose.
Wir fangen anders an, wir machen zuerst den
Git-Post-Receive-Hook. Wir machen, wir machen
zuerst, wir machen zuerst den
Git-Post-Receive-Hook.
Also, wir machen, also,
wir machen ein Docker-File, dass wir den Preisschamp
verdockern, äh,
kontinuieren können. Dann machen wir ein
Docker-Compose-File, wo
wir, ähm,
das dann starten können mit.
Dann können wir dann auch Ports angeben,
wobei, kann man im Docker-File auch. Man kann
zumindest automatisch die Sachen dann, ähm,
restarten lassen und so was.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Dann
schauen wir, dass
in dem Git-Hook
Docker-Compose gestartet wird
und den, den Preisschamp neu startet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt verstanden...
Chat!
War das zu Hackerman oder hat man das verstanden, was ich machen will?
Hab, hab die Nacht
auch erst 2 Uhr mit der Aproxy
Keepalive...
Achso, Keepalive-D
äh, Cluster Management gemacht, was?
Muss man, muss der vorher nicht
noch bauen?
CD direkt ohne CE, exakt.
Wir machen einfach Git-Push,
Git-Push und dann ist es da.
Weil es ist ein Projekt
von einem Mann, oder, oder
von einer Person.
Mann ist ja heute auch schon fast Hate Speech.
Ich muss mich langsam mal
zusammenreißen, sonst kommen die Leute wirklich noch an hier.
Und Shitstormen rum auf der anderen Seite,
ganz ehrlich. Gibt
eigentlich wenig, was mich weniger jucken könnte.
Ähm...
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen, und zwar, genau,
das ist ein Projekt von einer Person
und,
äh, auch
Deployment von der gleichen Person
und Tests von der gleichen Person.
Scheiß auf, CE.
Vielleicht mach ich noch, vielleicht, wenn
es mir irgendwelche Sachen dabei auf den Kicks gehen,
mach ich noch irgendwelche GitHub-Action-Tests oder so was.
Oder lass es über GitHub-Actions machen.
Was sollen die, was sollen die machen?
Deinen YouTube-Kanal canceln?
Ey, ist das so weit, ist das so weit hergeholt?
Wenn, wenn, wenn sogar, wenn sogar
Trump gelöscht werden kann von Twitter,
dann kann, dann können die alles löschen.
Dann können die auch mich löschen.
Ich will aber nicht gelöscht werden.
Weil aktuell läuft's gut auf YouTube und
mir macht's doch wieder Spaß, YouTube zu machen.
Grüße aus dem Homeoffice, ja, Grüße zurück.
Die Gurkenarmee, exzellent.
Habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, wieviel fake Trump-Accounts
es mittlerweile auf Twitter gibt?
Hast du vor, den Bundestag zu stürmen?
Also wenn schon, wenn schon,
dann würde ich, dann würde ich das in einer Sache
so machen, wie Trump das auch gemacht
hätte.
Ich würde das nicht selbst tun.
Also wenn ich das machen
wollte, dann würde ich es nicht selber machen.
Dann würde ich irgendwie mir was ausdenken, warum
das das andere für mich machen.
Aber ich hab's auch nicht vor.
Deswegen hab ich da, muss ich mir da gar keine
Gedanken drüber machen.
Coded auf deine Arbeit?
Hier mal mit Emojis.
Ich mach in commit-Messages ganz
gerne Emojis.
Also Leute, wir machen weiter.
Genug gelabert.
Was wollte ich jetzt machen? Genau, wir wollten
den Preis-Champ
wir wollten den Preis-Champ
containerisieren.
Haben wir noch uncommittede Sachen?
Menü, Max
Price.
Ok, das haben wir gestern gemacht. Also
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man
eine ASP.NET Core Anwendung am besten
verdockerisiert.
Deswegen fragen wir mal unseren Freund,
ob der das weiß.
ASP.NET Core
Dockerfile, da gibt's bestimmt
Guides dazu.
Hast du oben links in der Ecke
einen FPS-Counter? Ja klar.
Wer hat, wer nicht?
Es ist doch enorm wichtig, dass man
auf seinem Desktop einen FPS-Counter
hat, dass man zum Beispiel sieht, dass
C-Matrix gerade mit 24 FPS läuft.
Oder sogar das
oder sogar das ASCII
Aquarium.
Oder die allerbeste 3D-Demo
aller, oh der ist gar nicht drauf, ok.
Ich hab kein GLX
GLX Gears, oh
kein GLX Gears?
Alter, äh
Wie hieß denn dieses Tool
nochmal? Genau.
Moment, Moment.
GLX Gears.
Ah, yes, alles gut jetzt.
Jetzt bin ich beruhigt, jetzt haben wir GLX Gears.
Oh, noch viel schlimmer.
Die schlechteste Demo aller Zeiten.
Ich weiß nicht, warum so was
überhaupt als Demo enthalten ist.
Das hätte noch nicht, guckt euch mal diese High-Res
Bäume an.
Ich mein, das hätte ja noch nicht mal
Ups.
Das hätte ja noch nicht mal aufm
aufm, äh
das wäre noch nicht mal auf
64 hübsch gewesen, das wäre auf
wo wäre das jemals hübsch gewesen?
Nirgendwo.
Aber immerhin ein 40 FPS, ja.
Was soll das sein?
Irgendeine Mesa-Grafik-Demo.
Vor allem, was macht das Feuer da für
komische, warum
spritzt das so komisches Feuer aus?
Na ja.
Ich will da gar nicht näher drauf eingehen.
Bloodpack, Dankeschön
für den Sub.
Exquisite Subscription.
Im originalen Doom wäre das hübsch
gewesen, nee. Das originale Doom sah
deutlich besser aus.
Nee, das soll Feuer sein, das Programm
heißt Fire, deswegen würde ich mal von ausgehen,
dass das Feuer sein soll.
Auf der PS, ey, selbst auf der PS
1 wäre das nicht hübsch gewesen, das wäre
noch nirgendwo hübsch gewesen.
Okay, dockerize
ASP.NET Core-Application, exellent.
Ich wusste doch, dass das schon irgendjemand
für uns gemacht hat, also.
Introduction.
Ja.
Pre-Requisites, alles klar.
Create a Docker-File, ja, das wusste
ich auch schon, dass man das machen muss. Und dann hier.
Copy-Paste, easy.
Easy. Heute, heute ist Copy-Paste-Tag.
Also. Touch.
Wobei.
Docker-File.
Wenn dann Arduino das macht, dann ist es hübsch.
Ja. Das würde ich mir doch
durchgehen lassen, ja.
So.
Pasten wir das Docker-File und wir stellen fest, dass da
wahrscheinlich
die Hälfte nicht funktionieren wird, weil
wir haben eine.NET 5 Anwendung.
Eine
Windows-Container-Dockerize.
Okay, das ist natürlich richtig
Panes-Champ.
Also, wir haben
.NET 5.
Ja, ich glaube
einfach mal, dass das jetzt
hinhaut.
So, aber die DLL heißt
Preis-Champ-DLL.
Preis-Champ.
Aus 3 wird 5.
Ja, das ist Microsoft-Logik.
Hinterfragt das wirklich
irgendjemand, warum nach 3.15
kommt?
Ich meine, warum kommt nach Windows 8, Windows 10?
Microsoft ist geübt da drin, komische
Dinger zu machen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das werde ich gleich sehen.
Wahrscheinlich stimmt die Uhr nicht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man Core-Werken
auf dem Computer
wegmachen muss, weil es jetzt nur noch.NET heißt
oder so.
Zeile 13, nochmal?
Ach so,
ja, habe ich doch gerade gemacht.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt, das müsste man eigentlich auch noch
Dark-Theme machen für
So,
jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das bildet.
Also,
Exzellent.
Docker-Build.
Bam.
What the fuck?
Ah, Moment, da sind ja auch die ganzen
Node-Modules und sowas mit drinne.
Und das stimmt auch nicht, okay.
Nee, nee, nee, die Node-Modules muss ich exkluhen.
Ich brauche im Prinzip nichts, ich brauche nur
den Source-Folder.
Nein, keine Node-Modules, Leute, keine Node-Modules.
Wie hießen der Kram nochmal?
Ignore.
Nicht gete... Was einfach?
Docker-Ignore?
Zeig mal.
Docker-File.
Docker-Ignore.
Exquisite.
.NET Asp.
5 ist das Richt... Ah, okay.
Siehste? Gut zu wissen.
Bin, ja, das kommt rein.
Client-App kommt rein.
Also, sprich, das, was da nicht reinkopieren soll.
Was für ein... Das ist
äh, der, der, der, der neue
Compton-Fork ist das.
Das ist das, was man verwenden kann. Leute, ich warte
noch drauf, dass Compiz mit I3
funktioniert. Mir fehlen so sehr
Wobbly-Windows. Ja?
Wobbly-Windows ist das Beste, da würde ich
den ganzen Tag hier rumwobbeln lassen.
Peacom, ja.
Kann Peacom Wobbly...
Kann Peacom mittlerweile Wobbly-Windows?
Ja, Wobbly-Windows ist das allerwichtigste.
Irgendwelche Low-Effort-Memes.
Wobbly-Windows ist das Beste.
Kann das Ding mittlerweile zoomen,
wenigstens?
Was? Peacom...
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Ah, das ist irgendein...
Warum machen die das alles teilweise
den Leuten so kompliziert?
Was ist...
Compiz geht...
Nee, Compiz...
Also, Compiz geht unter I3.
Das Problem ist, dass Compiz
ne komplett eigene
Windows mitbringt.
Also, du kannst dann I3 nicht mehr so
verwenden.
So, und das kann zoomen?
Das wäre poggers, wenn das zoomen kann.
Ach nee, das ist irgendwas anderes.
Was auch immer, wir machen jetzt bitte
eigentlich den Sachen weiter.
Salgu...
Ich hab doch auch keine Ahnung,
was ich mache.
Was ist das denn?
ein alt champ mit grafikfehler ich freue mich auf unser meeting wann mieten wir keeper
xy wann mieten wir ich muss mal in meinen kalender gucken ich wusste gar nicht dass
wir mieten in nächster zeit
freitag athema firewall hä ich weiß auch nicht was sie wollen
ok also du bist eingeladen ich bin eingeladen und der tim der weiß ist auch nicht
hä ok was auch immer ich muss manche muss manche meetings muss man nicht verstehen
ich will da ist jason's von dir will ich das was ich ergeblich alles will nein ach
jetzt weiß ich um was es geht ne die wollten die frage war ob das überhaupt
sinnvoll ist einzubinden und ich bin der meinung das ist nicht sinnvoll einzubinden
ich will das überhaupt nicht im wiki stehen haben das soll im firewall tool bleiben ich
will das überhaupt nicht haben es total sinnlos warum soll man das nachbauen egal
können wir uns dann können wir uns am freitag drüber unterhalten deswegen mieten keck
weight das baust du seit letzter woche ja keine ahnung also ich halte es nicht für
sinnvoll aber wir reden da wir reden da lass mal morgen drüber reden bevor du dann noch
weiter baust was da eigentlich angesagt ist aber leute jetzt habt ihr wieder gesehen wenn
man in irgendwelchen big stonks im big stonks banksektor arbeitet dann macht auch nicht
alles sinnen was man so erledigen muss also das kommt schon öfters mal vor dass dort
dinger entschieden werden von denen die es umsetzen müssen nichts wissen und umgedreht
arbeitsmeetings über twitch also so wo sind wir stehen geblieben ich habe jetzt docker
feil gemacht und ich habe docker ignore gemacht ne genau so was muss ich noch mal was was
muss ich da jetzt noch rein reinhauen also im docker feilen beim docker bei der gelegenheit
kann doch gleich mal docker compose anlegen das brauchen wir gleich data data will ich
auf jeden fall exkluden gibt es gibt es gibt es das gegenteil von einem ignore feil gibt
es ein docker include feil ach das ist ja cool beste ja perfekt
das machen wir das ist viel besser wie wir ignorieren everything und wir inkluden nur
das ist nämlich viel einfacher wir inkluden nur ww root das ist dann anders rum ist vielleicht
doch besser ich will auf keinen fall meine datenbank inkluden oder irgendwie sowas docker
wird nicht schlecht gemacht die docker leute haben sich selbst ein bisschen ins knie geschossen
in letzter zeit aber doch ist an sich immer noch eine coole geschichte docker ist halt
mittlerweile nicht mehr so essenziell also es gibt viele andere container frontends ja
von kubernetes bis potman und wobei kubernetes ist ja eher so der orchestrator drum herum
von potman dann hast du die ganze co os die nicht mal co os heißen sondern co os heißt
jetzt glaube ich flat car weil die coolen projekte benennen sich alle drei jahre mal
um das sind immer weiß was was ist ok wir machen das jetzt von client app und db die
datenbank will ich auch nicht haben ok ansonsten will ich alles inkluden wunderbar passt ok
jetzt war mein docker bild gibt es nicht aber der chat hat eben gepostet um was es geht
was genau ist docker ein frontend für liegungscontainer es gibt dem kernel eine funktion für liegungscontainer
liegungscontainer sind nichts anderes wie eine sandbox für programe das ist keine vm
deswegen finde ich den vergleich mit vms immer fail die leute fangen an und sagen containers
ist so ähnlich wie eine vm nur ganz anders man sollte den leuten erst gar nicht sagen
dass es so ähnlich ist wie eine vm weil es hat mit einer vm überhaupt nichts zu tun
es ist ein sandbox für prozesse und eine weitere komponente wo man den prozess und
sachen vorgaukeln kann die in wirklichkeit anders sind aber sag einfach es ist ein sandbox
für prozesse und jeder versteht was gemein ist und docker und dieses sandbox funktionalität
gibt es im kernel es ist eine mischung aus einmal cgroups und namespaces das ist so das
was für die sandbox gebraucht wird das ist im kernel drin und docker ist quasi nur ein
user interface für diese funktionen wenn man wenn man beispielsweise linux capi kernel
api programmieren möchte kann man mit zehn zeilen c oder c++ mein wegen auch container
starten das ist gar kein großartiges ding docker hat das nur ein bisschen angenehmer
gemacht ok was genau es heißt net ohne sdk habe ich jetzt gelernt wie sieht eigentlich
das heizungs management aus naja das gucken wir uns heute nicht an ok also so kann ich
jetzt mein docker container bilden exquisite ok ja die images und die registry und so das
ist eine reine docker geschichte ursprünglich gewesen muss man sagen mittlerweile ist davon
vieles standardisiert und und potman kubernetes und sonst was die verwenden alle das gleiche
container format das ist jetzt open open container heißt das glaube ich sogar einfach nur und
deswegen die fressen alles das heißt docker braucht man eigentlich gar nicht mehr wirklich
aber ich finde es trotzdem noch recht angenehm gerade das ganze ökosystem drum herum was
sich so etabliert hat in den letzten jahren was macht er da eigentlich so lang gerade
oh resource temporary unavailable warum
kann das sein dass mein docker nicht ins internet kommt warum kommt mein lokaler docker nicht
ins internet das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ganz
ja das lädt aber auch der host das sp dot net package das wird jetzt im container ausgeführt
wisst ihr was bär so mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
genau so das wird sein das wird sein hat letztens im stream einer gesagt das wäre homophob
mittlerweile wird es die leute von allem getriggert repo repo preis jam build jetzt geht's ne ne
der versucht nicht meine ab von nur getrunter zu landen der versucht sich die dependencies
von meiner app runterzuladen das hat nicht funktioniert aber reboot easy funktioniert
warum weiß man nicht aber es geht ok jetzt können wir mal gucken ob ich meine app starten
kann ähm wie geht das nochmal genau so also jetzt lassen wir das container image mal laufen
unser preis jam läuft im container sehr gut nicer preis jam wie oft hörst du beetles
gar nicht gar nicht war weit vor meiner wobei die anderen sachen die ich hören war teilweise
auch vor meiner zeit spickel der keks also ob der keks eine frau
ist oder nicht kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten weil ihr wisst ja was der keks hat
ok der preis jam läuft also docker images images ls wie groß ist das 259 mb ist das
image das geht eigentlich das ist im prinzip dass das das das war image plus bisschen was
von meiner anwendung ist in ordnung das ist warum hatten der so viele images angelegt
beim nächsten bild ist es dann kleiner ok naja wunderbar also docker file funktioniert
schon mal was habt ihr jetzt mit no sql hat irgendwie einer was zu no sql gefragt bitte
erkläre mir no sql über mal prüfen hat man nicht gelernt alter was will was was willst
du genau wissen also die einfachste antwort ist warum no sql no sql heißt weil es halt
eben kein sql ist sondern alles als dokumenten speichert der große unterschied zwischen
sql und no sql ist das no sql überhaupt no sql heißt es heißt es ziemlich doof eigentlich
sollte no sql document store oder irgendwie sowas heißen also in der regel ist es so bei
sql speicherst du die dateien letztendlich auch irgendwo unten drunter entfallen auf
der festplatte aber das macht die datenbank für dich und du kannst die daten quasi strukturiert
mit einer abfragesprache abfragen so und das was so in der reinen leere erstmal sql versus
no sql hat ist das sql hat relation also sprich die daten sind miteinander irgendwie verknüpft
also du hast einen kunden account und der account hat verschiedene bestellungen und
sowas in der richtung das kannst du in der sql machen das kannst du zwar auch in no sql
machen aber das ist dann eher obendrauf gesetzt no sql ist eigentlich eher ein reiner document
store also sprich du nimmst du nimmst einfach einen json document gibst ihm den key und
den value und speichert das ganze also im prinzip ist no sql ein riesen key value store mittlerweile
ist der unterschied aber rein von der funktionalität her gar nicht mehr so groß weil lustigerweise
die ganzen sql datenbanken wenn man sich postkrass mal anguckt auch ein bisschen in richtung
no no sql support gegangen sind also man muss sich mal angucken postkrass hat volltext suche
mittlerweile folgt hat hat support für time series database und sowas also das das geht
schon alles ein bisschen mehr universelle richte wohingegen auch die no sql datenbanken
so eine art query language mittlerweile haben und so also das ist funktionalitätsmäßig
nähert sich das an was die fünfte normalform ist ich habe keinen platzen schimmer
irgendeine geschichte wie du besonders effizient daten speichert in der daten was auch immer
keine leute ich weiß noch nicht mal wer das osi modell ab auswendig soll das war osi modell
physikal date nee ich habe keine ahnung ja date ist es wirklich data keine ahnung ich
habe wirklich kein schimmer ich weiß es nicht mehr auswendig ok also unser docker container
ist gebildet exzellent funktioniert ist auch nicht allzu groß was im prinzip egal ist
weil wir wir pushen den ja nirgends wohin jetzt lasst mal überlegen was habe ich gesagt
muss man jetzt machen wir wollten eigentlich erstmal den gethug machen ok kommando zurück
wir machen erstmal den gethug auf dem server ssh mkd app natürlich alles als root was
sonst letztendlich ist es egal docker läuft eh und als mehr oder weniger root was juckt
jetzt können wir das auch als gut machen so app also normalerweise ist das so es gibt
zwei unterschiedliche sorten von git repos es gibt so ein normales git repo was ihr kennt
wo dateien drin liegen und es gibt bär repos die im endeffekt plus diese git verwaltungsstruktur
haben und normalerweise kann man in in normale git repos nicht rein pushen weil man dann
sachen überschreiben würde was dort im verzeichnis liegt so aber scheiß drauf das kann man mittlerweile
option setzen dass es trotzdem geht so wir machen jetzt remote auf unserem server erstmal
ein repo und jetzt fügen wir dieses repo hin zu lokal bei uns im price champ ordner git
remote add das nennen wir jetzt keine ahnung test git wie auch immer root add 18 ist das
ist das ist das richtige ja anscheinend punkt app geht immer mit minus minus force ja in
die git konfig einfach schon default minus minus force machen genau ex exzellent so sorry
sorry sorry natürlich nicht git jetzt haben wir das hinzugefügt nicht shit nicht shit
wir hatten mal so ein spezieller zubi der hat das habe ich euch schon 50 mal erzählt
aber das ist einfach beste sache überhaupt gewesen der und der zubi musste eine präsentation
halten das machen die bei uns so wenn die azubis in paar abteilungen gewesen sind dann
machen die eine präsentation was sie in den abteilungen gemacht hat gemacht was was sie
in den abteilungen gemacht haben und er hatte eine präsentation da sitzt dann unter anderem
auch der abteilungsleiter und sowas drin also das sind jetzt nicht ganz unrelevante leute
drin und dann hat er gesagt in dieser präsentation ich muss jetzt gucken dass ich den namen nicht
sag also er hat sachen ins git repo eingecheckt ja und auf der präsentation hat er gesagt
ich habe so sinn so sinngemäß hatte ich war kriegt genau ein wort laut nicht mehr hin
zumindest hat er gesagt ich habe ins ich habe ins shit ich habe ins shit gepusht oder irgendwie
sowas eingecheckt ich habe ich habe ins shit eingecheckt hat er gesagt und die leute hatten
natürlich absolut keinen plan von was der typ überhaupt meint und die haben gedacht
er will besonders cool sein auf der präsentation jetzt und hat dann irgendwie gesagt ich habe
ich habe gerade krass den shit eingecheckt und was auch immer ja waren voll empört
erst mal bis dann einer dabei gesessen hat er gesagt ach du meinst unser git repo okay
die hat ihn dann korrigiert hat ihm so halb das leben gerettet er das hat er glaube ich
gar nicht realisiert und seitdem nennen wir das alles aus spaß an der freude shit anstatt
skit einfach nur weil wir uns ein spezieller zubi am start hat das shit ausgesprochen
hat ich weiß übrigens auch warum er das shit ausgesprochen hat das hat er sich nicht ausgedacht
wir hatten einen bei uns im team das hat er von uns das weiß wir hatten einen im team
der hat alles geil aus der hat alles besonders cool ausgesprochen da war nicht nur emerson
da war auch war auch hiera war gira und und hiera und und und jit und alles der hat alles
jubantu der hat alles besonders geil ausgesprochen und der zubi hat halt gedacht okay der typ
hat ahnung der spricht das shit aus also spreche ich das auch shit aus rauter er garantiert
rauter 100 pro hat er er hat nicht geroutet geroutet rauter massive jubilee der also wir
haben das git repo initialisiert jetzt pushen wir mal push push git push test habe ich das
genannt master geht nicht so das kommt immer wenn ihr versucht in git repo zu pushen was
kein bear repo ist aber aber man kann den g baiten nämlich indem er ihm sagt das juckt
uns nicht aber ich weiß aus dem kopf gar nicht wie das geht git config nur für dieses
repo das da auf oh nee wie ging das noch mal ok ich muss nachgucken google easy git push
non bear repo excellent excellent aha update instead alles klar ich kann es einfach hier
raus kopieren beste so macht man das stack overflow triffen das spart zeit wenn man sich
das selbst nicht überlegen muss und jetzt geht der pusher jawoll so ok jetzt haben wir
unser git repo auf dem server drauf das alleine bringt noch gar nichts jetzt müssen wir das
machen was ich eigentlich vorher für machen uns ein git hook also mein ziel ist folgendes
vielleicht noch mal zu erklären also das ist der source code vom preisschamp preisschamp
ist hier meine meine preisvergleichseite die übrigens alle ausprobieren können für
nämlich preisvergleich meine store tracker seite wo ihr nachgucken könnt wo grad hardware
verfügung ist könnt ihr euch alle selbst angucken betapreisschamp.org das ist das sourcecode
dazu so und ich mache es aktuell so richtig habt ihr habt ihr schon preisschamp heute
spring's by the way man kann sich auch hier richtig nice crafts anzeigen lassen wo man
sieht das ist der uvp 3080 uvp 700 euro und koste aktuell 1428 im durchschnitt normalerweise
hat der git server keinen branch ausgecheckt das ist richtig das kann man folgendermaßen
machen mk dir blub so ups dann sagste nämlich git init minus minus bär so da könnt ihr
auch mal sehen was ich hier mache also ich habe hier jetzt einen dockercontainer draus
und mein plan ist dass ich nichts anderes machen muss als ein git commit und push und
der server stoppt den alten container startet den neuen und mit ein paar sekunden downtime
ist die neue version da ohne dass ich mir dass ich nichts mehr machen muss aus git push
das ist das ziel so jetzt habe ich ich habe den git repo angelegt und hab es einmal gepusht
die ganze geschichte und jetzt müssen wir dafür sorgen dass die anwendung auf dem server
gestartet wird das machen wir über docker compose das ist dann relativ easy weil docker
compose kannst du so dinger sagen so wie es soll wieder gestartet werden wenn es aus ist
oder welcher port das verwenden soll wie es gebaut werden soll und docker compose kann
auch wenn es ein neues update gibt vom config fall die anwendung stoppen und die neue anwendung
direkt wieder starten so und damit das bei einem push automatisch passiert brauchen
wir den git hook die liegen im git verzeichnis unter hooks und da gibt es jetzt ein post
receive hook der nicht da ist ok wahrscheinlich weil es kein berg repos mit downtime wollen
wir mal leute wir überprüfen mal wie lang die downtime ist also wenn man wenn man das
nicht haben möchte möchte mit downtime könnte man zum beispiel auch hergehen und sich zwei
server nehmen also natürlich könnte man auch die cloud native big stonks architekten sachen
machen und erst mal sich einen kubernetes cluster aufbauen für downtime loses deployment
man kann es aber auch man kann es aber auch nur mal kleiner machen man könnte sich einfach
zwei server mieten oder vielleicht sogar einfach nur einen server und ein reverse proxy davor
machen der das laut balenzt könnten wir alles machen aber tja es geht auch nur mal kleiner
es muss nicht immer der kubernetes cluster sein ja mit sim links ja gut das funktioniert
bei php weil er wahrscheinlich jedes mal bei jedem request die seiten neu einliest dann
funktioniert das bei asp.net wird nicht funktionieren genau du kannst den traffic als
proxy davor machen also es gibt es gibt genug genug möglichkeiten das das zu machen ich
habe cloud flair davor davor von dem eigentlichen server ich könnte mir vorstellen dass cloud
flair das sogar auch in irgendeiner art und weise kann das laut balenzen auf unterschiedliche
server irgendwie keine ahnung also das überlege ich mir dann aber mal ganz ehrlich die 2 die
23 sekunden downtime vom preis champ die werden wir glaube ich überleben ok post receive hook
da steht nicht allzu viel drinne gut also in den post receive hook der läuft wenn ich die
sachen gepusht habe preis champ dauernd naja zwei sekunden so also wenn ich hier irgendwas
pushe zum beispiel hier und sobald das fertig gibt das ist ja ich weiß das ist es ist nicht
hyper agile und es skaliert glaube ich auch nicht so gut wie ich das jetzt mache und der
passende cloud native enable architekt wäre wahrscheinlich damit nicht satisfied mit dieser
lösung weil das keine low hanging fruit ist also da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob das
so gut ankommen würde vor allem wenn man das im daily scrum dann vorstellen muss glaube
ich die sache eh nicht ist die sache eh gelaufen aber für mich als projekt für den einzelnen
mensch mit einzelnen server reicht das ja so und was er geht hoch macht ist wenn ich
den pusch ausführe und sobald er pusch fertig ist dann läuft dieses kript einfach einmal
das kann ich euch zeigen also ich muss erst mal eine änderung machen ich muss jetzt noch
öfters pushen gibt es hier eine datei wo ich wo ich sinnlos änderungen drin machen kann
ohne dass es nicht schlimm ist touch lulvee alles klar die datei brauchen wir jetzt geht
at lulvee geht echo eins nach lulvee wobei das müssen wir gar nicht machen ich kann
es einfach amenden und force pushen geht ja genauso geht lulvee kommt wieder weg changes
not stage vollkommen der ist vollkommen okay push also kann ich einfach sagen hier gibt
ich commit minus m minus minus minus m keine ahnung docker test oder so und dann wird gepusht
und dann muss ich force pushen sonst klappt es nämlich nicht immer force pushen so und
jetzt sollte beim pushen der hook laufen sollte eigentlich der hook laufen da hier remote
123 der hook läuft exzellent habe ich bloß gerade nicht gesehen war das oben auch schon
da läuft die webseite wieder über deinen server jaja das sind 16 kerne server das ist
ein big stonks kiste also was heißt über meinen über den ich gemietet habe netter
steht nicht da steht nicht bei mir irgendwie rum oder so ich habe nicht den ich habe nicht
den mobile first approach gewählt ja das stimmt das stimmt aber aber ich habe den ich habe
den mobile funktioniert auch ganz gut approach gewählt warum hat er derart viele kerne weil
der im hintergrund 190 chromium instanzen laufen hat die crawlen
ich könnte meine eigene kiste nehmen aber dann müsste ich das ja über mein voter von
internet anschluss machen das ist von der anbindung her halt sack ich doch man kann
das garantiert besser machen aber manche shops funktionieren nur mit javascript da gehts
mit reinem html passen schon mal nicht und manche haben auch clevere protection die gucken
ob es ein echter browser mit einem echten user ist das heißt in den simul also in chrome
der user aktion ist simuliert und das abgreift ist auf jeden fall weniger fehler anfällig
so also unser commit hook läuft jetzt geben wir jetzt kopieren wir uns einfach mal irgendeinen
git hook von github genau den da den brauchen wir jetzt und schmeißen die hälfte raus
weil ich die grundsätzliche sündung aus dem kopf nicht weiß ja das sieht schon mal
ganz gut aus branche master das brauchen wir alles nicht das brauchen wir auch nicht wobei
bash kann man bisschen mehr machen das brauchen wir auch alles nicht eigentlich brauchen wir
nix davon 0w echo reload docker irgendwas da ich was sehe das brauchen wir auch nicht
mal pushen und gucken was passiert oh sündungs error habe ich habe das if kaputt gemacht
weil ich bin das gewöhnt dass dann auf der gleichen zeile steht reload docker alles
klar branche main triggert das default ist master ich lasse jetzt auch erstmal was warum
eigentlich main warum nicht gleich 0w oder sowas wenn schon gleich richtige sache master
branche ist die sklavenhalter von github jaleigh schuss stufe 1 dankeschön für den sub exquisite
subscription bloß mal kurz den chat gucken ich glaube ich habe da ein paar sachen übersehen
ja kann man kann man ich hoffe ihr preis gemmt auch alle schön
ich glaube doch nicht so viel übersehen du hast guckt mal hier heute wenn das nicht die
beste die beste werbung für den preis schenken ist wisst ihr was leute leute warte mal ich habe
ich habe die idee ich habe die die beste idee wir machen testimonials für den preis gempt
ich machte bauzeite ich mach ne bauzeite ein laacht du scheiß das kann ich nicht aussprechen
ein like half wie auch immer man das ausspricht darf ich deinen darf ich dein deine chat message
als referenz dings angeben auf der seite ich mach leute wir brauchen jetzt ganz viele messages
wie geiler preis gempt ist und da mache ich in die baut page in die baut page mache ich dann so
nach dem motto der champ ist der beste dank mein dank dem preis gempt was bekomme
perfekt das mache ich das mache ich dann hier ich mache in der baut page noch drunter baut
und dann geht man dann kann man dann sehen so nach dem motto ich habe gechämt und und nicht
gepennt oder irgendwie so fälliger also seit ich den visitor counter anhabe waren es jetzt
glaube ich 3500 aufrufe in in drei tagen oder so ich meine für das dass ich nirgendwo was
gezeigt habe ist es schon durchaus in ordnung irgendjemand hat es bei my deals gepostet
deswegen ich habe total viele referer von my deals ja noch das mit dem snippen tool
kenn ich irgendwie habe ich das so angewöhnt bescheuert gibt es als generators für nutzer
stories garantiert übrigens leute wisst ihr was ich mir registriert habe twitch.tv preis
champ
wo pok da mache ich dann einfach 24 sieben stream mit einem bot im chat oder die leute
schreiben können xt 30 90 ab 900 euro und der bot registriert das und notifiziert notifiziert
dann die leute im chat ja also big stonk sind unterwegs leute ja excellent moment
0 follower 4 follower der preischef er wird nicht gesagt hier mit hier mit ref links verteilt
ok leute weiter weiter ok weiter jetzt müssen wir erst mal wir müssen erst mal big big
brain defops deployment machen ja also so funktioniert es jetzt einfach so wie ich
bin das forschen einfach docker compose ab minus d also wenn ich wenn ich richtig denke
sollte das alles sein was wir in diesem hook brauchen ach nee vielleicht sollten wir noch
ins richtige verzeichnis wechseln da bin ich mir nicht sicher ob das ob das notwendig
ist komm wir machen das wir machen das schick wir machen das schick ist ja defops vorzeige
defob stream deswegen macht man alles und alles als root so der überprüft jetzt ob
wir master pushen wenn wir master wobei wisst ihr was viel cooler wäre nicht wenn wir master
pushen sondern wenn wir prot pushen oder so da könnte ich nämlich unterscheiden zwischen
testserver und nicht testserver eigentlich gar keine so schlechte geschichte wieso nicht
preis ab es gibt 30.000 varianten über das nennen kann bei uns staging bei uns bei uns
nicht bei uns heißt test entweder test oder wir sind ja ein deutsches bankunternehmen da
ticken die uren langsamer bei uns nennt es sich abnahme umgebung ausgeschrieben zusammen
abnahme umgebung nicht als ob das ist wirklich so das heißt für uns so glaubt mir wieder
keiner ist der keeper xy noch da der kann das bestätigen das heißt bei uns so abnahme
umgebung die leute sitzen auch wirklich in irgendwelchen besprechungen sagen jetzt ich
habe die abnahme umgebung die pleut ist ernsthaft das ist gar ein umgeber tja da machst du nichts
ok also das haben wir unser was heißt bei euch abnahme um unsere test umgebung heißt
abnahme umgebung da kann ich da das ist was da kann ich nichts dran ändern das liegt
nicht in meiner macht da was dran zu ändern dass sie das so nennen so also funktioniert
jetzt die docker kompost geschichte status so jetzt enden wir erstmal alle änderungen
und pushen ok prinzipiell funktioniert der würde docker kompost starten ok das müssen
wir ausprobieren wir brauchen who am i container das ist so ein hallo welt container der nix
anderes macht außer hello world zu printen ich brauche docker kompost minimal example
kann man nicht merken mit version fängt das irgendwie an what the fuck sprach docker kompost
im fall hier excellent das brauchen wir also im docker kompost jawoll das kommt alles font
who am i image image who am i perfekt so mehr brauche ich glaube erstmal net so und jetzt
von der idee her was jetzt passieren sollte wenn ich das pushe dann sollte der auf meinem
server in docker container starten der who der who am i heißt das wird später in einer
price champ container ok gucken ob es funktioniert top level objekt need to be an object
ah
ach ich hab das gar nicht geedit ich kack noob alda
lull
deswegen geht das nicht
bäm funktioniert
you might see in this error you are using wrong version file
ok
mein docker compose ist zu alt für die version welche version kann er denn
kann er nicht
ok punkt drei kann er die was nicht name was nicht ich muss mal kurz was
nachgucken war das nicht name ich habe doch
irgendwas docker compose example sag mal benutzt ffmper irgendwie ein komisches
fad format nö also zumindest nicht unter linux compose ich brauche einfach ein
beispiel alda gibt mir ein beispiel servicers things name name ist da nix
ist die einrückung die einrückung ist ok docker compose name
name container name na gut dann ist nicht name ist container na natürlich klar was
sonst also ab wann hier stand aber ab wann was unterstützt wird also docker
version docker compose minus minus version 127 ach so das die docker engine
ok docker minus minus version 20 10 und warum kann ich nicht 3.8 verwenden jetzt
verstehe ich nicht was hat er für schmerzen mit 3.8 das mag er nicht aber 3.3 mag er
ich habe ihr falschen server geguckt lull docker ich muss ja auf den server gucken ich
muss ja auf den server gucken nicht verbauß version 1903 kann angeblich
3.8 ok was auch immer das verstehe ich jetzt nicht wirklich aber ich nehme es
jetzt mal so hin dass 3.8 nicht funktioniert kill cut ich würde gern
ein bisschen mehr programmieren auf der arbeit aber ich bastel ja hier privat
genug da habe ich gute ausgleich so gut kommen wir nehmen einfach punkt 3 wir
bauen eh keine features also das sollte von der idee aber jetzt funktioniert
push ich das und da sollte ein container starten mit den docker container um mal
ja bär macht er auch so docker ps und der container läuft also sprich der
git der git hook startet einen docker container und jetzt ist die frage
update der auch den docker container wenn ich wenn ich an der anwendung was
ändere also nehmen wir mal ein anderes container image kann immer mehr latest
oder so noch mal neu pushen re creating guckt der kann quasi automatisch das
ding neu starten wenn es was neueres gibt das ist äußerst praktisch und das
machen wir jetzt mit dem preis gemp auch da nehme ich nämlich nicht den nicht den
who am i container sondern den preis den preis gemp container und danach gucken
wir mal ob wir in das docker feilen nicht noch die ganzen crawler und so mit
reinkriegen und und cpu limit brauchen wir cpu limit für die crawlers probieren
auch gleich aus ob das funktioniert ok also was service heißt jetzt nicht mehr
also wo immer sondern preis gemp container name preis gemp image gibt es
nicht da muss gucken wie ich ein bild mache docker compose docker feil bild
wenn man nichts reinschreibt macht er ein bild
echt da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wie kann ich eine simple filter funktion in
in typescript mit ok ok muss man meine ruhe angucken also wie was kann der who
am i container der ihr könnt den wir probieren den aus leute wir probieren
who am i container aus aber ich beantworte das mal kurz noch die frage
na super jetzt kann ich euch mal ganz jeffrey ich beantworte gleich mal kann
ich euch mal kurz hier ein nice ein nice get get hack zeigen ich habe jetzt
mehrfach die comments überschrieben also ich kann jetzt nicht mehr zurück rollen
die comments weil ich sie überschrieben habe aber es gibt eine sache habt ihr
mal was gelöscht in git und ihr braucht unbedingt was wieder get ref log also
ist eine historie von allem was ihr gemacht habt oder kann ich jetzt quasi
hier zurückspringen auf den stand wo noch das richtige drin stand das ist
richtig nice so jetzt beantwortet man die frage von jeff als jeffrey sister fragt
wie kann ich eine simple filter funktion in typescript mit ajax
schreiben für die uni bekomme keine ergebnisse bei google raus typescript
gut du willst wahrscheinlich typescript im backend mit not oder so und verwenden
oder hast du not irgendwie gerade geschrieben und ajax in not kann not das
überhaupt hat not hat auch so eine eigene http
kleint api oder kann not fetsch not fetsch
not http request genau die haben nämlich eine eigene die haben nämlich eine
eigene api für http request neben irgendeine neben irgendeine sucht ihr
irgendeine library raus für not mit denen du angenehm http request machen
kannst und dann nimmst du den den den string der da zurückkommt von diesem
request und sagst keine ahnung includes was auch immer du da filtern willst und
dann ich weiß ja nicht was du ab was du was du was abfragen oder willst du von
der api was abfragen oder willst du von der api was abfragen also sprich du
weißt was da an struktur zurückkommt ja weiß ich ob gibt es axios für not
dann dann der ist wirklich nice den kann man echt gut verwenden aus einer
sql datenbank php my admin das sind jetzt das sind jetzt aber ganz schön viel
unterschiedliche dinger zusammen php my admin
du kannst keinen direkten request gegenüber der sql datenbank machen über
über über web ja das versteht es das leuchtet mir gerade nicht ein also in
web request kannst zum beispiel hiermit machen das einfach in deinem projekt
installieren und dann haben wir hier schönes w8 beispiel dann machst du so
was hier w8 axios get und dann deine uhr also wenn du moment sollst du keine
abfrage machen kann das sein dass der will dass du das backend programmierst
über den man eine abfrage machen kann das wird nämlich da wird das wird
nämlich viel viel mehr sinn machen sollst du denn ach du sollst das ok dann
vergisst das mal alles was ich gesagt habe das dann stimmt es auch nicht was
du am anfang gesagt du willst keine du willst kein ajax call machen du
möchtest das backend programmieren zu dem an ein ajax call macht also quasi du
programmierst das backend und jemand anderes connectet sich zu deinem backend
und du gibst ihm die daten dann note express server also habe ich mit note
noch nicht gemacht ich habe von note backend keine ahnung note express gs
du machst den note server das ist eigentlich relativ simpel hier guck dir
mal das hello world an ich habe selbst noch nicht gemacht aber das ist relativ
easy genau das ist im prinzip erstmal alles was du brauchst dann hast du den
server laufen und port 3000 und dann musst du einstellen was bei dein
request passiert und in diesem request musst du dann halt einen query gegen die
datenbank machen und die daten zurückgeben
entweder nimmst du dafür irgendwie keine ahnung mysql postgres sqlite library
für note oder du machst per kommandos also per per kommando zeilen aufruf
das muss man im detail eher wissen aber also wenn ich das mit note machen würde
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich mit express machen weil zwar das einzige was
ich kenne was note backend ist
so aber jetzt wird jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal unsere history an wo noch das
richtige in der datei drin stand ist die hier ist nämlich noch
hier ist nämlich noch wo ist unser wo ist unser compose file ja da compose
excellent geht check out docker compose und bäm haben wir die alte version wieder
obwohl ich das kommet überschrieben habe ich weiß ich auch mit irgendjemanden
vollen konnte aber geht reff lock wenn ihr irgendwas gelöscht habt was
irgendwann mal im git repo bei euch lokal drin ist könnte mit greff lock den
kram immer wieder herholen obwohl das kommet über bügelt ist okay was wollte
ich jetzt machen ich wollte ich genau ich wollte euch zeigen dass der who am i
container funktioniert also push
rating who am i alles klar jetzt gebe ich euch mal den port frei da
könnt ihr nämlich selbst ausprobieren dass es funktioniert mit dem who am i
container also public IP 8000 oder so machen wir jetzt der ob das frei ist
port 8000 ist frei ok also machen wir jetzt ufw allow 8000 zack
und jetzt sagen wir dem hier ports
ports
ich glaube port 8080 muss man das so mappen sehen wir jetzt gleich guck
re-create das ganze wenn wir klück haben
ist nicht port 80 was ist denn die fall part vom who am i container null
geht das nicht
weil ich in kakno bin das ist die wie sports musik weil ich in kakno bin weil
ich das falsch gemacht habe weil ich das falsch gemacht habe ich habe die
firewall freischaltung nicht die firewall sache nicht richtig gemacht
in status
wenn ich geht status ich muss ich muss ich muss die regel löschen ich habe die
firewall freischaltung falsch gemacht jetzt wie wie löscht man noch mal eine
regel delete
und jetzt die liet zwei
jetzt die liet drei ich habe das falsch gemacht
docker ufw das ist ja das ist ein container image das muss ich anders
freigeben und zwar muss ich das folgendermaßen freigeben wir sind jetzt
wieder stack stack overflow driven hier da war es da das da
if you want to allow public network to access the service provide by docker
container for example port 80 ok das brauchen wir ich habe den port raus
genommen in der jamme ne habe ich nicht also port 8000 haben wir gesagt
haben wir gesagt bäm und jetzt pushen wir noch mal jetzt jetzt fack ok warum
nicht
muss ich jetzt auch noch lauport 8000 ok ich wohl mal ob das local host geht
köln local host port 8000 ja das geht so sollte das eigentlich auch sein also am
docker liegt nicht das ding läuft alle ich kann echt nicht tippen mehr oder ok
port 8000 das läuft auch also das müsste eigentlich funktionieren aber
meine firewall regeln sind nicht richtig vermute ich mal
habe ich irgendwas vergessen sonst ok das ist irgendein firewall problem ich weiß
jetzt nicht warum es von außen nicht funktioniert wenn ich ehrlich bin jetzt
eigentlich erwarte dass es funktioniert ufw allow 8000 vielleicht muss ich das
noch mal so auf die ufw reloaden
echt
da dran kann es nicht liegen das macht er normalerweise gleich
ne ne da dran liegt es auch nicht ufw allow muss vielleicht so noch mal
erlauben ok passchamp das geht nicht ah not the host port moment was
moment
jetzt geht's ok ihr könnt ausprobieren chat also das macht der who am i container
da kommt ihr jetzt öffentlich drauf der macht nix außer zu sagen dass er da ist
liegt auch fack schon wieder lull also nix nix wildes macht der container
ja der sagt dir die ip vom server und und meine ip
o nee sind idee dass er jetzt am start ist ist er geht aus wieder raus leute
ich glaube da war nur ich glaube da war nur kurzzeitig etwas überfordert dass
so viele leute auf einmal drauf zugegriffen haben ok also ihr seht es
hat funktioniert jetzt lösch ich den kram mal wieder delete kann man da
mehrere sachen angeben also sowas wie 8 8,7
und jetzt heißen muss man das echt einzeln machen
das sollte da nicht überhaupt kein ein ein fluss drauf haben
hier plus kein ssh löschen jetzt
den moment jetzt geht es wieder nicht stimmt jetzt wieder weg ist wieder weg
ufw die lied 1 wäre keine so gut hier dann spreche ich mich aus lau geht das kann
ich sowas hier direkt die lieten du bekommst noch 200 das glaube ich dir
nicht oder doch doch das kann sein weil er die weil die weil die session noch im
contract drin ist vielleicht könnte sein okay wie löscht man hier wieder was
die liet
man hat sogar ein script dafür da wie man das machen kann das ist
tatsächlich ganz praktisch mal gucken ob es das als script direkt im paket
manager schon gibt
oh das sound in chinesisch erst mal oder was auch immer
ok alles klar dann geben wir das ganz jetzt noch mal frei und probieren das
mal mit dem lau aber aber warum muss ich da port 80 war muss statt den container
port sagen das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn
die vier mal die vier mal die achter muss man die private ip das ist aber
schon echt ein bisschen umständlich ok wir machen das mal für port für port
80 machen wir das mal rein und unser container soll einfach port 80 laufen
und gut ist senpi dankeschön ja ja jetzt sollte es wieder gehen leute
excellent hacky 406 dankeschön für den primes ab
vielleicht kommt das gem train ok jetzt machen wir weiter zu der eigentlichen
geschichte ich machen wollte also das deployen damit funktioniert
so jetzt gehen wir repos preis jam echte legenden eben den mikro bot container
was denn ein mikro bot container
gut also jetzt passen wir unser docker feil wieder an und zwar auf den preis
jam das heißt auf port 80 sollte gleich der preis jam laufen allerdings ohne
inhalt sage ich euch gleich weil hier drauf ist nichts keine datenbank und
nix also port einfach nur 80 für den preis jam es reicht container name
preis jam image gibt es nicht sondern ich wollte gucken wie man bildet wie
macht man docker kompo spilt docker feil
hmm wie funktioniert das docker feil docker feil bild einfach nur so
einfach nur bild
oder quasi
docker feil so
ok einfach so docker feil ok probieren wir jetzt mal aus also von der idee her
ich war jetzt mal erst mal die ganzen sachen wieder weg von der idee her sollte
der jetzt den preis jam pushen und bilden auf dem server und dann und dann
hochfahren gutes anfängerprojekt in java nee ok
schauen wir mal was ist das jetzt
building price jam ok ich habe irgendwas verkehrt gemacht
bild docker feil
ah kann das ach so ach so muss man das angeben
so muss man das angeben ok aber im moment nicht hier sondern noch zwei so
und jetzt docker feil kontext punkt so was da ob man auch einfach nur bild
punkt machen kann ok pusch
ah guckte mal guckte mal jetzt pullt er den kram und startet es auf dem server
das ist jetzt übrigens alles was man hier sieht ist das was hier eigentlich
hier oben auf dem server passiert guckt der ist jetzt hier grad
was
preis jam feil to build but why warum
ok das nicht kann er sich da irgendwie nicht hin konnekt
microsoft timeout moment das ging doch eben noch
ok ping tut das prinzipiell nicht
ich lösche mal die dinger lokal dann müsste die neu pullen mal gucken ob das
was was ah ja ja was was die pendet denn hier jetzt noch
ach so der akt der läuft noch oder was
ich muss jetzt erstmal die ganzen scheiß gelöschen wartet mal
alles weg brauche ich alles gar nicht mehr alles komplett overrated ok gut
ach stimmt genau sie platzt wieder ok und jetzt jetzt sagen wir noch mal bild
und jetzt gucken wir ob es lokal funktioniert warum kann er das lokal
fetschen und auf dem server nicht
die russischen den aus dass er wieder am start leute
das quitt alles könnte neben wir haben kein quitt gesetzt das ist wirklich ab
alter die russischen den aus dass er wieder am start ok
das quitt sollte da jetzt eigentlich nix mit zu tun haben weil er ist ja gar
nicht als proxy eingestellt aber wir stoppen ihn mal man weiß ja nie
was ich reboot den kram einfach mal vielleicht habe ich mit meinem firewall
rum konfigurieren irgendwas kaputt gemacht als quitt stoppt ich mal preparing
shut down ja prepare mal shut down ok bild der kommt da echt nicht hin
ich meine ich kann ja auch schlecht geblockt sein
ich habe nix gemacht ok wisst ihr was beim weiß nicht warum aber ich rieche
gerade mal
vielleicht den skit gleich ausschalten soll dass immer noch da der server
warum das denn oder schon wieder da moment
aber das ging aber schnell jetzt habt ihr gesehen
ok warum kann mein docker nicht nicht zum zum nicht zum microsoft container
registry das kann doch was nicht stimmen
blacklist wehen was
ich habe doch auch nichts gemacht
try changing your dns changing dns from 8882 autobot
oder musik anmachen dass das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ich mein docker run hello world
wo ist der hello world container über den run können docker run hello world
was ist hier los was hat er denn für schmerzen karte ich gucke mal kurz bei
hetzner rein und ich habe riebungen ab jetzt dazu gemacht na gut ich will ich
habe sie auf der anderen seite ist themen top skit disable
aber das ist das ist hochgradig merkwürdig
was ich das gar nicht so viel das haben wir schon gemacht
ok
das geht das geht der kann pullen also von der von der offiziellen docker
registry kann er pullen passt alles skit ist ein proxy auf deiner kiste
doch sehr merkwürdig oder mcr haben wir noch was anderes sind das deine ersten
versuch mit docker ja die ersten die nicht funktioniert zumindest
was ist das problem die kenne ich werde mich so warum ich habe nichts gemacht
ich muss ja drauf lokal hat es doch auch gebildet
dem asp.net ping man den surfer die dinger antworten nicht auf ping
wo findet man eigentlich diese wo findet man eigentlich offiziell diese
dinger von microsoft wo die wo die das haben die ip wird auch richtig aufgelöst
ist alles alles gut offiziell asp.net core bei image wo findet man hat
microsoft das ist ja auch nicht mehr core
woher weiß man denn diese url zum beispiel ich meine ich habe das jetzt in
dem in der beispielseite gefunden ach hier guck mal ok ok jetzt wirst
da geht keine verbindung what the fuck
docker hab limit das ist ja gar kein docker hab also das leuchtet mir jetzt
allen ernstes nett ein warum ich mich dahin konnekt aber wisst ihr was jetzt
können wir uns ein proxy verwenden lull
jetzt jetzt random eisen wir einfach unsere ip
also wie kann man die wie kann man docker sagen dass der docker use proxy
es reicht nicht es reicht nicht wenn man export htp proxy macht
ach es hatte die ps muss man machen ja wobei das haben wir nie eingeschaltet
was ist das problem dass er das älteste in ip zu dem server
ist ja was wir finden einfach eine andere registrie asp.net core
asp.net
excellent das nennen wir jetzt einfach gut ist wir nehmen das einfach von dem
anderen
depo preis champ
wir nehmen jetzt einfach nicht das sondern das andere so hier 5 4 was zum
teufel ist 4.8 warum ich 5.0 immer durch
das verwirrt mich echt richtig krass was passiert wenn ich das einfach weg
lasse die framework repos ich habe das noch nie verwendet okay ich habe kein
plan warum das nicht funktioniert ich meine lokal lokal tut das guck mal das
was 5.0
wo hast du die gefunden wo haben die das offiziell stehen
ich habe die seite noch nicht gefunden
also irgendwas ist da merkwürdig warum bin ich da gepleckt ich habe doch
überhaupt nichts gemacht
ich werde vom server aus geht es nicht
aber von mir lokal aus geht es da kann doch schon mal irgendwas nicht stimmen
hier ist die übersicht moment da war ich doch gerade hier warum geht das nicht
lokal funst alles das verstehe ich nicht
ich meine netzwerk technik ist er doch technisch ist er doch auch alles in
ordnung passt wunderbar
ja
sind da noch irgendwelche ip tables regeln also ich wüsste nicht welche ip
tables regeln
namens auf lügen so geht auch alles
restart hat nichts geholfen ein bisschen ufw gedöns aber das ist ja ein
da wüsste ich nicht was da irgendwas machen sollte
ja ja das funktioniert das normal das geht das haben wir schon längst
ausprobiert das funktioniert alles der mag nur der mag nur die microsoft
register nicht das heißt ich ich ich aus irgendwelchen gründen vielleicht ist
hetzen an sich gerade geplockt weil leute komische dinger gemacht haben
ich meine ich habe nix gemacht
das auflösen geht das auflösen geht alles gut alles gut ja ich glaube keine
ahnung
ja ob ich die erreichen kann kann ich nicht so ohne weiteres ausprobieren
wir können kann man einen telner drauf machen oder so was lul wie ernsthaft kein
telner drauf
moment ich habe doch mit squid irgendwas verkehrt gemacht moment
wartet mal keck weight moment warum hat er sich meine proxy konfig gemerkt ich
habe riesen warum hat er sich meine nee nee das ist richtig aber ich habe den
neu seit wann ist meine proxy konfig noch da nach einem neu was der fuck das
verstehe ich nicht nicht aber es geht immer noch nicht
mal gucken ob das lokal funktioniert
kann aus gründen die sich mir nicht erschließen wir microsoft selber nicht
erreichen
kann er eine andere ist eine andere ip verwenden custom outgoing ip das klingt
doch schon mal ganz gut
jojo ja so habe ich mir das überlegt
oh ok ich bin auf jeden fall geplogged ich weiß nicht warum ich mein ich habe
nichts gemacht anders kann ich mir nicht erklären aber vielleicht ist er der
russische der russische dedos hexor clever gewesen hat mit meiner absende
ip irgendwas gefaket oder so
das ist eine gute idee wir können traceroute machen
traceroute war in netotils
nee das ist nicht ein server von microsoft es ist irgendeinen load
balancing eingang und ich habe ich habe exakt die gleiche bei mir lokal guckt
mal ne quatsch die das ist das ist in den cdn von microsoft aber du siehst
die einkommen die eingang eingangs ip ist ist genau die gleiche da ist ok
traceroute
interessant aus gründen die sich mir nicht erschließen
das liegt das liegt nicht an namensauflösung ich darf schlicht und
ergreifend wirklich nicht hin die plocken mich ich weiß nicht warum ich
habe den server aufgebaut und nichts damit gemacht warum ich habe legit
keinen blassen schimmer
ja
kommst du da von anderen ip ich habe hier noch jede menge anderen ip ist
ich müsste ich müsste dem nur irgendwie er verklickern dass der eine andere
outbound ip verwendet das weiß aus dem stegreifen nicht wie das funktioniert
ip vom vorgeil schon auch bei ms auf der plockliste vielleicht ja
outgoing ip
oder sonst nicht ok das könnte tatsächlich funktionieren
aber warum bin ich geplockt das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn
ne aber andere also vielleicht vielleicht es kann durchaus sein dass
leute die in meiner ip range sind kann nicht zu microsoft kommen oder chat
der chat stack overflowed mit exquisite es nicht perfekt so du bekommst auch
nur timeouts ernsthaft ok dann probierst du mit anderen ip sauce das ist docker
das ist docker hier das ist das docker netz oder das ist das docker netz
irgendwo da sonst im 17 to sauce ja ok welche nehmen wir hier da bärm
hier pull
t-marks auf was will nachgucken ob er die jetzt auch nimmt erst mal ein tcp
dampf installieren ok wir könnten auch explizit filtern aber
pull pull nee
aber die ip tables regel müsste eigentlich passen oder all davon soll
die hier benutzen ne ne ne klar der macht das aus dem ach so ne stimmt der
container ist das ja ja ne ne das pull macht der host ich muss jetzt quasi
mein default ip irgendwie so standard gateway mäßig änder oder was auch immer
die kammer lilox global sagen was für eine ip default ist das geht normalerweise
nur also das ist halt standardmäßig die erste
linux die change irgendwie so was ja ja ich will die aber alle behalten dass
dass ich einfach mein ip erinnern kann ist klar die route bringt nix wobei das
ist ein anderes netz das könnte tatsächlich funktionieren
ach das ist diese komische hetzner konfig ne das funktioniert nicht das
funktioniert das ist diese komische aufwacht den datran kann ich nichts
ändern ne ne ne datran kann ich nichts ändern das ist diese komische diese
komische hetzner geschichte wo der geld wäre im anderen netz ist wie die ip da
kann ich gar nichts wenn ich datran dran rumdrehe dann geht gar nix also ohne
scheiß würde sagen ich bin geplockt warum auch immer
ok ich glaube ich war bei hetzner ein
ich sehe da kein da ich mache auch kein proxy
wir machen jetzt krieg 17 ich macht es anders meine ich muss mal kurz bei
hetzner einloggen ich habe das Fenster zugemacht weil ich Kacknoob gewesen bin
ich erinnere jetzt die ip etzner so jetzt muss ich erstmal den ganzen scheiß wieder abtippen
login ich habe ja mittlerweile to factor authentifizierung an dass dass ich nix
legen kann
otp muss rein
OTP wo ist mein OTP so OTP das ist etwas echt umständlicher
der sagt mich beeilen dass ich das OTP noch erwische cloud und stream alles gleich mache
ich wieder an die neue Hetzner IP was bringt ja denke schon
ok Hetzner hat ja gedacht man kann das ganze nicht ändern deswegen habe ich jetzt big brain
idee wie wir das doch machen zwar wir machen jetzt einen snapshot snapshot
ja ja kaufen wir alles gut
ach so man hätte man hätte die server vorher ausschalten sollen glaube
ok ist gut Hetzner schalt aus alles gut
public IP kostet 1,19 pro Monat
und jetzt legen wir den zweiten server an teuer naja geht doch
jetzt legen wir den zweiten server an und restore den snapshot
habe ich noch nie gemacht und jetzt dann haben wir eine neue IP easy
weil man kann sie nicht direkt selbst ändern
auf snapshot go go go wir können der zwischenzeit schon neuen server anlegen
natürlich alles schön im stream dass gleich wieder russland botnetz gededost werden kann
jetzt server wir nehmen wir nehmen klein nun bärsch den kleinsten den skipped ssh key jawoll
so wenn der snapshot fertig ist, restoren wir den gleich
also jetzt hier zack server der ist aus wunderbar der ist an snapshots
kann man das irgendwie machen kann man die snapshots umhängen
du kannst sie sogar auf ein anderes Projekt transferieren
wie geht denn das jetzt habe ich noch nie gemacht
Backups
du kannst einen neuen server von einem snapshot kreieren
vielleicht hier irgendwie
ach create new server so geht das ok na dann hellzinki jawoll
warum sieht die site jetzt anders aus
ok create
können wir den hier wieder löschen
hätte so einfach sein können oder exquisite name perfekt
den brauchen wir snapshot 30586366 upunto 4g nbg 11 jawoll
der ist perfekt so wollte ich schon immer dass man server heißt
so der ist weg den können wir abbrechen
jetzt warten wir mal bis das snapshot wieder da ist
stimmt ich hätte hellzinki nehmen sollen
irgendein anderes rechenzentrum falls die ip range gebannt ist
das war doof das war doof verschieben kann man die ja nicht
aber wir gucken mal wir gucken mal restoren
exquisite mario kart
op snapshot
hättest du nicht warten sollen bis zum delete ich habe den anderen server
deleted oder was meinste ich habe den anderen delete den ich
angelegt habe der nichts damit zu tun hat
status leist am oberen rand das ist i3 wm rust heißt das ding glaube
ok
copy
da sind wir exquisite pull
ha wir waren geplackt listet
ich sagt euch hier ist irgendwie der russische denossa im start
im stream der find das lustig chat chat wer ist es
gab es zu der find das lustig wie ich dann probleme hab
vielleicht war es aber auch vom vorgänger der komisch gd
aus hat ok docker images jetzt lösch ich den kram noch mal
so und jetzt probieren wir das mal mit dem pusch aus jetzt muss ich aber erst
noch mal sagen mit remote ads gits remote set url set url
protest geht und zwar auf das war die richtige ip ne
jetzt guck mal ob es funktioniert ah guck mal jetzt bildet er auch richtig
sneaky boy
dankeschön für den sub vier monate
du warst das exzellent
ich schneise heckermann von von 2020
sollte man öffentliche IP in der 30 maximal 24 das kann schon sein aber ich will ja keine
24 stunden warten ums auszuprobieren
ok jetzt sollte der preisschamp hier laufen leute
port 80
also
da is er
äh warum hat der
das ding ja doch mal eine datenbalt mit committed lokal oder
ich mein wo hat das wo hat das daten her
18 uhr 14
nein es geht bei euch wahrscheinlich ne aber was mich verwirrt wo hat er denn wo hat er
daten her
er crawlt doch gar nicht ich hab die das docker docker ignore
ne warum hat der preisschamp daten jetzt hä
das ist irgendein bug
warum hat der preisschamp und warum aktualisiert der überhaupt
ach ich weiß woran es liegt
ich weiß woran es liegt
ich hab doch im frontend die url hardcoded
der geht zum richtigen preisschamp jetzt gerade
der geht einfach zum anderen server gerade über cloudflare
jetzt war ich echt verwirrt gerade
by the way leute das ist nicht die letzte version die wir gestern gemacht haben
das ist nicht die letzte wo sind wo sind die neuen buttons wo sind die neuen buttons hier
ok da können wir das nämlich gleich mal ausprobieren
so und jetzt jetzt können wir nämlich mal live deployment ausprobieren ob es funktioniert
am 24 um 21 uhr haben wir das gemacht aber
das ist nicht die neue version das ist nicht die wo man hier drauf klicken kann
das haben wir doch gestern leute das haben wir doch gestern zusammen im stream gemacht
was haben wir bescheuert haben wir doch gestern haben wir das hier zusammen im stream gemacht
um 21 uhr beta branch ne ich hab ich hab nur ich hab nur ein branch hier
der beta branch gibt es nur auf dem anderen
server price diff poc expand hä ne da ist es doch
schon gepusht ja aber ich hab das frontend nicht gebildet
deswegen daran liegt ok ich bin jetzt echt grad übelst verwirrt also alles klar jetzt
wir machen jetzt live wir machen jetzt mal live live deployment mal gucken ob das funktioniert
wie ich mir das vorstelle also ich ich mach ich mal so als wäre ich da nicht per ssh eingeloggt
also repo price champ build ich muss erstmal das frontend nochmal machen dass er das refrescht
so und von der idee her muss ich jetzt einfach nur pushen und dann startet es neu ihr erkennt
die neue version übrigens daran dass er sich merkt ob dark theme oder light theme aktiviert
war und dass diese buttons hier wechseln das komplette ding klicken kann das was wir gestern
gebastelt haben also geht status es gibt neue dinger ja neues frontend gedünstet das könnt
das lagern wir übrigens auch noch aus würde ich sagen so und jetzt machen push ja passt
jetzt war mal ein push reload docker price champ ist up to date warum ist der price champ
jetzt up to date ach genau der kapiert das ja nicht ich muss
es ich muss das neu bilden kann er nicht irgendwie nachgucken ob er das neu bilden muss stimmt
du hast recht also docker docker compose ach nee das muss ich mal im hook machen hook
post receive und was meinst du musst da hinten dran minus minus bild macht er dann aber jedes
mal ein rebuild oder ist er so schlau und macht irgendwie den den hash von den dateien und
guckt warum baust du sowas selber weil das ziemlich easy ist für mich alleine das so
zu machen da brauchst keine github actions und muss nichts auf github pushen captain
sie kein dankeschön neun monate exzellent ok also bild ok push nochmal das ganze ja ok
jetzt bildet er das neu und gleich sollte er das automatisch updaten
recreating price champ dann recreate immer und jetzt ist der price champ weg warum
liegt es am browser oder geht es bei euch noch jetzt habe ich kaputt gemacht leute jetzt
habe ich jetzt habe ich kaputt gemacht not found hier warum nicht ok das funktioniert
nicht so wie ich mir das gedacht habe warum sind die untracked ach das ist der shit den
ich gestern noch nach gestern zwei minuten nein das ist der mist den ich zwei minuten
bevor ich oft gegangen bin noch noch ausprobiert habe dann habe ich noch nicht geändert da
habe ich auch nicht mehr dran gedacht dass den kram noch gibt ok haben wir gepusht ok
price champ wird recreated da ist er und ihr seht der neue price champ
ist am start mit mit max button und einfach direkt hier drauf klicken ok und jetzt funktioniert
der kram nämlich das heißt wenn ich jetzt was ändern will ok das ist nice das ist richtig
cool also wenn ich jetzt was ändern will sagen wir mal hier irgendwie ich will jetzt
dass da eine eins rein kommt docker das fronten bauen lassen das wäre auch noch was ja das
wäre sogar noch cooler wenn wenn das wenn es das noch mit noch mit baut so also sagen
wir jetzt mal ich möchte jetzt hier also hier muss jetzt hier muss jetzt unbedingt
noch eine nule alles löscht er ja wieder ok wo kann ich jetzt hier mal was einfügen
das muss unbedingt da jetzt noch rein das das das muss das musste sein docker baut
doch das das back end so jetzt auch gut das ist das können wir tatsächlich noch machen
das ist eine gute idee muss nämlich das fronten bilden und dann pushen aber dann sollte dann
sollte er das kapieren da muss ich jetzt mal gucken wie man das wie man das fronten bilden
da noch rein bekommt das wäre natürlich enorm praktisch ich mein also lang daun ist ist
ist der preis champ auf jeden fall nicht so recreating jetzt ist es kurz weg drei vier
fünf sechs sieben acht ja so ungefähr acht sekunden was ist jetzt schon wieder das problem
was hat er denn für probleme habe ich irgendwas vergessen ich habe wieder vergessen der macht
er immer ok dass das ist echt gut wenn ich das ist wenn ich das ins docker bild mache
da muss ich nämlich nicht an diesen miss denken dass ich jedes mal den kram noch enden muss
vorher übelster müll man guckt euch das mal an gut das mit normalerweise wird man es in
der abfolge auch nicht machen normalerweise wünscht es enden dann mache ich ein ordentliches
kommitten dann mache ich ein push dass jetzt plus dass ich nicht 30 milliaren commits erzeuge
ok so ungefähr acht sekunden dauern ich glaube acht sekunden downtime kann man verschmerzen
oder was machen die ich weiß wenn man grad so wenn man grad so heftig am preis champen
ist da kann es schon mal sein dass man da im eifer des gefechts probleme bekommt wenn
es acht sekunden dauern ist laut balancer davor inakzeptabel ok nice also so wie kriegen
wir das das frontend noch gebildet dabei ja ich war noch ein ha proxy davor easy dann
aber das ist schwierig mit der datenbank ich kann die anwendung nicht zweimal starten weil
es ein sq light ist dann müsste ich das über die richtige datenbank machen so wie kriege
ich denn da jetzt mein frontend bild noch rein kann man das in diesem zweiten server
brauche ich nicht ich kann einfach zwei sachen zwei sachen starten auf dem gleichen server
aber das problem ist die datenbank dahinter weil das ist eine sq light datenbank weil
es das einfachste war und die ist ja dann unterschiedlich zwischen zwei gestarten
dingern oder ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ob zwei anwendungen auf die gleiche sq light
datenbank zugreifen können aber sobald ich das wirklich ha machen will muss ich dafür
den postgloss oder irgendwas verwenden so wie könne ich den kram jetzt hier noch
machen in diesem in diesem dotnet container ein bild machen für das frontend ja ich benutze
den df db austauschen ist an sich wäre das ziemlich easy docker probieren wir mal aus
wie das funktioniert docker bild view app genau ich beauftrage einfach den support die
machen das ja from ich will einfach nur bilden könnte ich nicht einfach dieses image hier
habe ich mir noch nie gedanken darüber gemacht wenn ich so einen step habe mit zwei unterschiedlichen
bild sachen die nacheinander laufen müssen auf was basierten dieses microsoft dotnet
sdk ist das ein ubuntu oder was ist das docker hab
weiß man worauf das basiert ist es ein ubuntu oder ist es irgendwas eigenes ach hier guck
mal buster slim ist das ein alpin oder nen debian ok und was ist die fault und was ist
die fault oder was weiß man nicht du kannst einfach ein zweites docker file reinschreiben
ok das heißt man kann das habe ich schon nie gemacht das heißt wir können einfach den
kram hier nehmen also im prinzip jetzt wird es aber advanced aber dann aber dann kommen
die dateien doch im unterschiedlichen verzeichnis raus oder kommen die dateien nicht im unterschiedlichen
verzeichnis raus weil hier kopiert er alles in in das working directory ach so nee ich
kann es ja nachher kopieren also ich sag jetzt einfach es ist view entf oder so und
nee ich will die bild tools nicht haben
das ist gut zu wissen aber ok wirkt ihr passt ja das kann ich jetzt im gleichen verwenden
ok das ist mir zu hoch das habe ich nicht gemacht was passiert jetzt eigentlich wenn
ich das so mache dankeschön für den prime sub was das ist ja zweimal from geht an ach
moment das steht ja schon drinnen ok jetzt checkt ihr das node image aus ein beispiel
file also du bildest erst mal ok man bildet erst mal dass die dort net app bild net hast
du bild view wirkt ihr source alles kann man das gleiche ach das macht man dann so in unterschiedlichen
abschnitten ok ok verstehe das ergibt eigentlich sinn das ergibt eigentlich sinn also das heißt
ich mache jetzt erst mal hier drunter wirkt ihr können wir auch ab machen ist ja egal
und worten wir das offizielle npm install ich habe das ich mache das lokal mit jahren
macht es einen unterschied kann ich das dann auch dort per npm machen wahrscheinlich webpack
bild copy view ab copy copy client app heißt das ding bei mir npm run bild in dann kommt
der nächste step mal gucken ob es so weit funktioniert oh pence champ ok ich habe was
verkehrt gemacht im ach moment ich habe sie im docker ignore file das muss ich raus machen
aber ich muss meine npm modules exkluden ihr habt doch hier bestimmt im repo eine docker
ignore oder hier hat meine lokal 30 milliarden npm modules docker file exclude der rest ist
mir auch grad zu zu echter war eine immer docker fall aber kein kein kein docker ignore
hat doch ach man kann ein docker ignore auch im sub directory machen oder wie du hast
node modules nee nee nee nee ich habe keine node modules im git achso stimmt dann ist
es jetzt ja nur bei mir lokal relevant dann ist es nur bei mir aber ich will es ja auch
lokal bilden können wir hatten doch vorher so einen so einen sternchen sternchen ignore
everything docker file und da hatten sie irgendwie auch noch so ein exclude beispiel drinne das
war falsch rum ok dann machen wir dann machen wir docker ignore hier auch noch dann nehmen
wir das hier raus dann nehmen wir das hier raus dann client app dann haben wir auch noch
ein docker ignore rein und das dann klauen wir uns das einfach mal hier ok macht das
einen unterschied ob ich package lock oder nicht also node modules auf jeden fall nicht
ok docker wild warum ist das jetzt so groß da soll doch die node modules ausdingen das
ist doch nie und immer so groß nur mit node modules ohne node modules ok funktioniert
jetzt das bilden bin ich ja mal gespannt nice nice guck mal ok weiter geht es natürlich
nicht aber webseiten sind sind six herr ja man macht heute nicht einfach nur eine webseite
ok
jetzt kopiert da irgendwann heißt es funktioniert
mache ein npm ci im docker fall da soll mir die node modules gar nicht entfernen da soll
die node modules ignorieren aber was er irgendwie nicht macht weil die node modules die sind
ziemlich passbar auf wenn ich nämlich die node modules lösche und noch mal bilde da
geht es richtig viel schneller aus gründen moment sollte sollte er nicht den kram haben
wir löschen den kram hier oder wir machen das irgendwelche kunden docker im images aber
ich habe einen container in use sollte die dinger nicht löschen eigentlich haben wir
ein neues bild hä warum warum es ist der kram nicht im docker container mit drinne
ich will ja nicht meine ganzen node modules und geduldens installieren guck mal da macht
doch npm install das sollte doch eigentlich den kram wieder runterladen oder nicht oder
doch
bild view wirkt dir so gut wie ich es nenne ist doch erstmal egal oder es kann auch durchaus
abheißen was sagt denn der offizielle copy oder der macht big brain logik was was macht
das ding da wirkt ihr app package jason npm install ach so die liegt ach ja die liegt da
dann an einer falschen stelle oder wie ist das no source files ich blick nicht durch
das ist mir zu big brain muss ich dem sagen dass ich klein app kopieren will also das
ist ja bei mir gar nicht da drin also quasi so das sieht schon besser aus das sieht schon
besser aus ok jetzt muss erstmal das gesamte internet runterladen damit er meine app bilden
kann guckt euch das mal an java script logik
boah das dauert ja 30 stunden ey danach bin ich wahrscheinlich da auch blacklisted ok
aber jetzt bildet er alles klar aber der casht sich den kram ja also insofern ist das nicht
so wild werden normale desktop überhaupt anwendung heute überhaupt noch entwickelt kommt drauf
an was es ist aber so web basierter kram ist halt total im trend weil du total easy ne android
app ne ios app ne web app ne pwa und ne desktop app machen könntest es ist dann halt auf
den desktop ne eklig elektron app ne ein bisschen pains champ ich sage massive pains champ
aber es gibt bestimmt noch die ein oder andere desktop anwendungen die entwickelt werden
unter windows ist halt das problem dass microsoft selbst kein gescheites ui framework am start
hat uwp ist ganz nett aber mit uwp kannst du die hälfte nicht machen und winui kriegen
sie ja nicht aus dem fenster genau uwp so und jetzt muss ich ihm am ende noch sagen
solls rüber kopieren oder checkt er das jetzt copy ahja from build view das müssen wir noch
machen genau nach app ww root genau genau genau genau ok das müssen wir unten im letzten
step machen from das heißt nicht build view das heißt bei mir build stage vielleicht
so ne ne build stage vielleicht soll ich das mal richtig benennen dann build stage und
dann kopieren wir from source dist nach app ww root ok das ergibt sinn noch mal ein build
machen was weil das not exist ok was genau ist falsch das ist nicht source es ist auch
app bei mir ne app app dist macht er da oben letztens nach app ww root ok wohin bildet
er denn ab wohin schiebt er das bild dachte auch nach ab und die folge ist auch dist oder
oder kleint ab dist wisst ihr was wir zielen mal in den container rein ab dist ne ab dist
ist es anscheinend nicht oder ist es da out wir zielen mal kurz in den container rein
da kann ich mir immer nicht die synthax von merken wie das geht docker exec ne ne warte
mal wie konnte man sich das filesystem von den bilddinger docker enter ne ach du große
scheiße das weiß ich doch aus dem kopf nicht ne ne ne it ach so der is not running muss
man den kann man das überhaupt zum bildcontainer starten ne wie komme ich in das filesystem
rein wie komme ich in das filesystem von dem container rein wenn der nicht läuft ich
meine das ist ja mein übrig gebliebene bildcontainer der läuft nicht von da dann gar nicht aber
ich muss mir doch mein übrig gebliebenen bildcontainer angucken kann aber starten kann
ich den nicht weil da ist da läuft ja nichts drin ich kann im filesystem gucken hier war
lib docker images oder irgendwie sowas du kannst den starten mit bash einfach run start ne ne
ok da bin ich da bin ich zu noobisch für genau das ist ne gute idee wir machen einfach
ne ne exec ne exec in das in das docker file und zeigen uns ne ne ls an das ist ne big brain
idee null ah ne moment ich muss ls slash app machen slash app so sein kehr hä what the
ok das funktioniert so schonmal nicht ok ich hab die ich hab die loge hier nicht ganz
verstanden muss ich das vielleicht muss ich das vielleicht am anf ne das kann ich da
ist es vielleicht klein app es ist nicht dist es ist nicht dist es ist oh ich weiß was
verkehrt geht ich muss überhaupt nichts machen das passt alles schon ich hab doch mein bild
so angepasst meine view config hab ich so angepasst dass das schon in ww route automatisch
geht das müsste das müsste stimmen ohne diesen der kopiert das schon automatisch da rein
dann mach ich nur den ich mach nur den den den den bildstep von dem danach excess docker
den bild wirkt dir ach die beiden sind getrennt aber aber kann ich das aber ich kann das wirkt
dir doch gleich ne nennen oder ok wenn die fs getrennt sind dann heißt das moment das
ergibt dann aber jetzt wait a minute keck wait das heißt ich kopiere dann slash app
ww route nach punkt slash ww route ernsthaft ich mein das müssen dann meine verzeichnisse
das kann doch im leben nicht funktionieren aber ich will in dieses verzeichnis reingucken
wo ist mein filesystem für den komischen container wo liegt das man kann sich das
containers der ist es der ist es die russischen hecker haben das gelöscht ok ich check nicht
bei dem song haben sich deine eltern kennengelernt ok dann exzellent ist das ist das irgendein
spruch den ich nur nicht kenne oder oder wirklich jetzt vielleicht des volumes ah hier da ist
das docker images wie heißt der krempel da warum ist das so groß volumes warum gibt
es da nicht manchmal ist es echt übelst hier die volume id wls docker images net docker
ps und dann eins things sieht man da irgendwie auch welches volume das ding verwendet da
sind wir ok da ist einfach nix drin docker genau docker inspekt wo ist das volume
ja ne doch also von volume steht jetzt hier nix oder du müsstest den image an die vom
container mit docker inspekt mit dem docker run entry point sh neuen container exzellent
so aber das ok wo finde ich denn jetzt hier die die was ist denn da von die volume id
das ne das da das da monka s naughty proskurika cover alles klar das da ist die image id also
jetzt mal was docker run entry point ok das geht schon mal net oder muss das da wo muss
das hin muss man das dazwischen machen kein pleasant shimmer was ich da mache überhaupt
ich mache jetzt einfach mal was der chat sagt ah yes guck mal da public heißt das nee sag
mal kann das sein dass der gar nichts gebildet hat hier ist einfach nix da hier ist einfach
nix da verstehe ich das jetzt nicht richtig oder npm run bild hat er gemacht sollte sollte
eigentlich machen ich meine meine app ist schon mal da das ist ja schon mal ganz ganz
gut dass dass die app an sich am start ist ja
aber da ist überhaupt nichts drin er näher da bin ich gerade dabei das ist das das ist
das bild image das ist das bild image da ist da ist überhaupt nichts nix drin ok ich lasse
ich lasse ihn jetzt noch mal bilden ich lasse ihn jetzt noch mal bilden ja kein wunder dass
er nix kopieren kann wenn er nix da ist das müsste unterhalb von app sein depot preis
jamper dockerfile ok ich lösche jetzt noch mal alle alle dinger
alter was das für ein speierplatz braucht da docker m immer ich lösche noch mal alles
jetzt sagt sagt sagt wir kommentieren jetzt mal den kram aus und machen nur wir machen
nur den nur den view bild machen nur das nie dann da kommen wir lassen was mal also das
kann ich machen also ich work in die app da ist alles drin klein klein er kopiert da dahin
dann macht ein npm install im moment kopiere ich das irgendwie drüber das müsste ich das
nicht umgedreht machen müsste ich nicht zuerst das kopieren das dann machen und und dann
so rum vielleicht falsch rum wir machen jetzt einfach noch mal ein bild alter das ist echt
nicht nicht ohne exzellent exzellent warum brauchst du beides da weil ich mein oh ne
jetzt muss ich den kram wieder installieren weil ich einmal mein frontend bilden muss
und einmal mein backend heutzutage macht man nicht einfach nur eine webseite nee nee nee
bei mir sieht so aus ok zeige ich mal her ja das sieht ja unterschiedlich aus und dann
kopieren wir gleich mal agi was agitated mandel lief alles klar moment
warum startet er da 50 milliarden container in dem bildprozess das mit dem
sp image habe ich gelöst bekommen ich habe mir neue api geholt dann war ich anplogged
er startet 50.000 container nach zwischendurch ok warum ist der container jetzt weg das ist
echt big brain ich darf nicht nachgucken ich habe keine ahnung ok kann man kann man hier
hier kann man ls drin machen so wir machen jetzt hier in ls drin und gucken uns an was
sache ist das stimmt ja da hast du recht macht er auch soll er auch
ein
Achso nee, von... Was hatte ich denn davor?
Hat funktioniert, man muss nur das richtige Verzeichnis nehmen.
Boah was ein Akt alter, wer kommt dann auf solche Pfade ey?
Von Slash-WWW-Route nach... Okay und das Output ist jetzt auch richtig, ja?
Okay, dann starten wir jetzt mal das Image.
It... Run... What the fuck?
Das liegt an meiner Viewconf, ja? Die habe ich extra so angepasst,
dass das halt einen richtigen Ordner bildet, wenn ich Lokalbild mache.
Okay, das funktioniert, das funktioniert. PS... So wie ging das jetzt mit dem
Exec noch mal? Container-ID... Nee, oh falsch rum, falsch rum.
Bin, Bash... So und da kann ich jetzt gucken, WWW-Route.
Da ist aber meine App nicht drin. Oder? JS... Doch, da ist die App.
Okay, ich glaube, ich glaube, es hat alles funktioniert, Leute.
Exquisite. Ich glaube, es hat alles funktioniert.
Okay. Okay, wir müssen jetzt testen, ob es funktioniert.
Also wir müssen jetzt mal irgendeine Fake-Änderung machen hier drinnen, wo ich direkt erkenne,
dass sich was geändert hat. Und zwar, wir schreiben jetzt da oben einfach
hin CACW. Das erscheint dann irgendwo unter dem CACW,
da steht dann einfach CACW rum. Build. Alter, der macht jedes Mal diesen Step.
Ich warte doch keine fünf Stunden, bis der den ganzen Crap installiert hat.
Dann mache ich doch lieber Jan-Build bei mir lokal.
Da muss ich das noch einmal machen. Kann man das nicht irgendwie...
Kann man das nicht irgendwie... Kann er das nicht irgendwie erkennen?
Kann er das nicht irgendwie... Checkt er das nicht irgendwie, dass der
das nicht neu komplett noch mal bilden muss? Bitte erst Copy Package Chasen, dann Install.
Okay. Okay. Excellent. Ich bin ja froh, das muss ich...
Ich muss euch da echt mal ab und zu loben. Mein Chat ist wirklich hilfreich.
Guckt euch mal den Chat auf den meisten anderen YouTube-Platt vor allem.
Das labe ich von scheiß, Alter. Twitch-Channels an.
Die würden jetzt da... Wisst ihr, wie der Chat woanders aussehen würde?
Null. He doesn't know. He lacks critical information.
Null. CACW. He is fucking noob. Null.
So was. Das wäre doch mal ein Chat. Okay, also.
Erst Copy Package Chasen. Okay.
Dann Copy Rest. Dann cached er das?
Ach so. Ach, jetzt verstehe ich's.
Okay, das ist logisch. Wenn ich das so rummache, dann erkennt er,
ab diesem Step hat sich was geändert, weil sich der Datei geändert hat.
Deswegen macht er alle vorhergehenden Steps noch mal.
Wenn ich so rummache, erkennt er, hier hat sich was geändert
und der Step vorher ist schon passiert. Aha. Aha. Okay. Okay.
Leuchtet ein. Äh. Was macht der da?
Aber ich hab meine Node-Modules immer noch... Moment.
Wie kriege ich meine Node-Modules exkluden?
Ich hab doch hier einen Docker-Ignore.
Da steht Node-Modules. Muss ich da einen Slash hinten dran machen?
Nee. Wie kriege ich dieser fucking Digger exkluded?
Docker-Ignore-Exclude-Sub-Exclude-Directory. Aha.
Rm. Das heißt, ich mach den Docker-Ignore hier weg.
Ich geh hoch und geh in den Docker-Ignore und sag dort
Client-App-Slash-Node-Module. So.
Ich check die Node-Modules auch nicht ein, aber ich will ja lokal
bilden können und lokal in dem Ordner hab ich die ja drin.
Ah, jetzt hat's funktioniert. Okay, exzellent.
Okay, das mach ich dann noch einmal den Install und danach teste ich das noch mal.
Danach muss ich wahrscheinlich nur eine Datei ändern und der hat die Sachen gecashed.
Der scheiß Gnome. Ja, der ist dran schuld. Genau. Preis-Champ, Docker-Champ.
Wisst ihr was ich als nächstes für den Champ mach?
Als nächstes mach ich den IP-Champ. Da kann man sich dann seine IP-Adresse abrufen.
Die Noobs brauchen solche Anwendungen. Das ist normal.
Das ist die übliche... Macht der da jetzt was mit Jan? Jan, Pre-Install?
Ach, Moment. Der installiert npm, installiert dann einen anderen Package-Manager und dann
mit dem macht er dann weiter oder wie? Was bei dem Docker-File musst du nach der
Package-Jason erst den Install und dann erst den Rest kopieren.
Ach so, stimmt. Ja, klingt logisch, klingt logisch. Ja klar, ja klar.
Dass er den Step schon hat. Okay, das klingt logisch, ja.
Genau, ich kopier den Kram. Und dann mach ich noch mal ein Bild.
Okay, leuchtet ein, ja. Da müssen wir es noch mal machen kurz.
Und wann kommt Paints-Champ? Ah, das ist schon Copyright.
Oh Mann, ist das kompliziert. Aber wisst ihr, was das Gute ist?
Ohne Scheiß. Dadurch, dass wir das ohne irgendwelche
komischen Cloud-CI oder sonst was gemacht haben, haben wir was gelernt, wissen, wie
es funktioniert und man kann lokal und mit eigenen Kisten so was deutlich besser debuggen
als in irgendeinem GitHub-Actions-Yaml-File oder so. Und dann dort Bildminuten verbraten.
IP-Champ. Exz-Excellent-Name-Idee. Okay, wunderbar.
Jetzt bildet er das.NET-Ding. Okay, und jetzt können wir mal pushen.
Was für einen Server hast du bei Hetzner geholt?
Die eigentliche Anwendung läuft, also der hier läuft auf einem 16-Kerner.
Volle Pulle, Alter. Den, den ich jetzt gerade hab zum Testen,
das ist so ein 3-Kerner. Den lösche ich danach ja auch wieder.
Den Bild musst du mit Jenkins automatisieren. Nee, wie gesagt, wenn schon willst du über
GitHub-Actions machen. Okay, ich glaube, es hat funktioniert, Leute.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, es tut. Ich glaube, es tut.
So, das heißt, was wir jetzt machen ist, ich starte den mal lokal, run, gucken, ob der
Preis-Champ läuft. Ja, lokal 80. Der wird nicht richtig, äh, hattet
ihr PS? Ich glaube, der ist nicht richtig forwarded
oder so. That's that.
Äh, Docker, PS. Ach, ich hab im Docker-File ja gar keine
Ports drinne. Ja, ja, ja. Ich hab die Ports ja nur in meinem
Compose drinne. Aber, okay.
Können wir das einfach mal hier... Jetzt bildet das natürlich noch mal, alles
klar. Welchen Webserver?
Äh, ich hab Cloudflare davor und, ähm, auf dem eigentlichen Host hab ich nochmal ein
Reverse-Proxy, und zwar Cutty davor vor der eigentlichen Anwendung.
Das hat aber eigentlich nur noch Gründe, weil ich damit mal so angefangen hab, weil
ich beispielsweise an der einen Stelle noch mein Prometheus-Monitoring dran gehängt habe
und die andere Seite nur per Basic-Auth mache.
Dem ich das jetzt ein bisschen verteilt hab, könnt ich mir vorstellen, hänge ich vielleicht
die ASP.NET Anwendung,.NET Core Anwendung direkt an Port 80 und lass da Cloudflare drauf
flair'n. Warum haben sie Musik fünfmal drinne?
Oh, wie oft haben wir das schon gestartet? Alter, vier Stunden! Wie, wie, wie, Moment,
wie, wie, ich hab gesagt wir brauchen ne Viertelstunde für den ersten Step und der Rest ist wahrscheinlich
auch easy oder irgendwie sowas. Cloudflare, Cloudflare ist, äh, DDoS-Protection
oder CDN klingt cooler, ähm, so ne Mischung. Die cashen Dateien von dir und wenn du ne Domain
hast und du machst Namensauflösung DNS auf die Domain, dann antworten nicht deine Server
IPs, also der DNS schickt nicht deine Server IPs sondern Cloudflare, das heißt die Leute
die die Seite aufmachen wollen gehen zu Cloudflare und Cloudflare leitet es weiter an deinen
Server. Bäm, der Preis-Champ, da isser, funktioniert, nice so, guck und auch keck W drinne, seht
ihrs? Funst. Könnt gleich ausprobieren ob das auch remote bildet. Cloud ist im, ja das
stimmt das ist im Prinzip wirklich sowas wie ein reverse proxy, passt eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hätte Daily Scrum machen müssen, dann wär das nicht passiert, dann hätt ich das
Docker-File ohne Probleme hingekriegt, weil wir wissen wer einfach möglichst viele Meetings
am Tag macht, der arbeitet auch am meisten, dementsprechend wir hätten einfach mal ne
Runde Stand-Up machen müssen Chat und dann gibts die Probleme gar nicht. Ok und jetzt
pushen wirs mal auf den Server und gucken was passiert. Ok, jetzt bildet er, jetzt bildet
er einmalig diese Geschichte, gut, kann ich mitleben, das muss er danach nicht mehr machen,
so und wenn ihr jetzt auf die Seite geht gleich, dann solltet ihr einen, ich hab schon wieder
vergessen, das ist schon ganz schön was man Server für ne IP hat, der da, dann solltet
ihr gleich den Preis-Champ mit keck W drinne bekommen, genau noch ist der alte Preis-Champ,
und sobald es deploit hat und den ganzen Kram da das halbe Internet Javascript mäßig runter
geladen hat, dann kriegt ihr den Preis-Champ mit keck W. Ob 16 Kerne beim Build von GS-Container
helfen? Bestimmt, bestimmt, aber der Server hat nur 3 Kerne.
So, auf Bilde mal. Chat und ich würd sagen gleich machen wir die nächste Sprintplanung
für morgen ne, ach ne morgen muss ich ein Video für YouTube hochladen. Übrigens, wie
krieg ich den dazu überredet, dass der die.NET Core Anwendung nicht bildet, wenn er
ne Vue.js bildet. Chat, ihr habt doch Ahnung von, von, von, von Dogger Files, wie es aussieht.
Ich mein, nur, nur weil er das eine ändert, muss er das andere auch nicht rebuilden. Kann
man die Build-Steps nicht irgendwie unabhängig voneinander machen? Gar nicht. Ne, aber rein
voll ist es ja egal wie, also jetzt ist es so, wenn ich die Vue Anwendung ändere, dann
bildet er die.NET Anwendung. Und wenn ich umgedreht machen würde, würde die.NET Anwendung
ändern, würde die Vue App bilden. User-Stories formulieren Story-Points. In der zweiten
Setsch kopierst du deine kleinen App-Anwendungen mit. Ja, aber wie soll ich? Ist das schlecht?
Soll ich das besser hier oben machen? Also quasi. Ne, ne, das passt doch schon. Das ist
der einzige Container, der dann am Ende läuft. Dann brauchst du zwei Container. Okay. In
dem Fall ist es halt nicht so, dass es voneinander abhängt. Also er müsste das nicht bilden,
um das zu machen. Okay, es ist auf jeden Fall noch optimierungsoptimierbar, ja. Hat das
jetzt einsch gemacht? Ja, nice. So, ist der neue Preis-Champ da, Leute? Bäm, der Preis-Champ
mit Keque ist da. Was mit zwei Docker-Files kannst du? Mehrere Docker-Files. Aha. Jaja,
das untere hängt davon ab, aber der mittlere Build-Step nicht. Das ist das, okay, das ist
nicht so einfach. So, also jetzt habt ihr auch den Keque-Preis-Champ. Und jetzt probieren
wir mal. So, jetzt mach ich das Keque wieder weg. Und ich push einfach mal. Das Vue-Ding
war schnell gebaut. Was? Eigentlich? Ah nee, das Vue-Ding kommt, bildet jetzt erst. Und
danach macht er noch das.NET-Ding. Ich mein, Leute, wisst ihr, was ich auch machen könnte?
Ich könnte mir einfach einen Build-Skript machen. Keine Ahnung, build.sh oder sowas.
Dann mach ich den Jan-Build-Lokal. Ich mach einen.NET-Build-Lokal. Und dann mach ich
eine Sache, die einfach die Outputs im Docker-Container zusammenkopiert. Ach nee, nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht, das geht nicht, weil auf dem Server, auf dem Server will ich ja die ganzen
Build-Tools nicht installieren. Nee, nee, auf Beta-Preis-Champ-Org nicht, nee, auf der anderen
IP. So, recreate den Preis-Champ. Jetzt müsste Keque weg sein. Bam, Keque ist weg. Gut, prinzipiell
funktioniert zumindest der Ablauf. So, man kann Multiple-Docker-File angeben.
Okay, das muss ich mir mal, das muss ich mir, glaube ich, mal offstream angucken. Ach ja.
Ach, dann hat man, aber man kann nicht mehrere, für den gleichen Service mehrere angeben,
ne? Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Also ich kann jetzt nicht sowas hier machen
in Form von hier irgendwie. Build das und dann nochmal ein Build. Das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren, ne? Aber da haben wir auf jeden Fall schon mal was gelernt.
Das könnte ich machen lassen. Ich könnte die beiden in unterschiedlichen Containern
laufen lassen, ja. Das Problem ist aber, der ASP.NET Container surft die Webseite.
Das heißt, da müsste ich, das ist eigentlich unnötig kompliziert dann.
Okay, das gucke ich mir dann mal off-steam an, wie das ist. Docker-Compose-Dependencies
und so. Zwei Service-Einträge, wie gesagt, zwei
verschiedene Container funktionieren so nicht. Das muss alles in den ASP.NET Container,
weil der surft die, das Frontend. Oder ich mache einen Base. Ja, aber da fällt
mir schon irgendwas ein. Die Idee, die Idee ist auf jeden Fall nice.
Der Preis-Champ zeigt bei mir keine Grafikkarten an.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist der grad beim Crop, na doch hier.
So, alles da. Ja, Amazon, Amazon kann sein, dass die uns
mal wieder geblockt haben zwischendurch. Muss glaube ich den Amazon-Timeout noch ein
bisschen weiter runter drehen. Da kannst du auch easy mehrere Frontends deployen
zum Scaling, ja genau. Nee, dann mache ich das Frontend gleich auf Netlify, das ist da
noch viel trendiger. Ein guter Sprint. Bei mir zeigt der auch keine
Grafikkarten an. What? Die sieht es bei euch nicht so aus wie bei mir. Ups.
Doch alles Grafikkarte hier. Das sind alles Grafikkarten.
By the way, warum ist der Preis-Champ heute eigentlich so schnell?
Gestern über Cloudflare war der ultra, ultra langsam. Heute, heute ist es der High-Speed-Preis-Champ.
Wobei, nee. Hälschinggrenzen. Der Dark Mode an Systempräferenzen nicht,
aber der Dark Mode, der wird gespeichert. Doch, doch, ich habe auch Mindfactory mit
drin. Aber wie gesagt, manchmal braucht der länger
als 15 Minuten zum Crawlen. Da kann ich jetzt nicht allzu viel machen, weil wenn ich ihn
schneller Crawlen lasse, sperren einen die Seiten. Das ist so ein bisschen, vielleicht
sollte ich den nicht verfügbar-Timeout auf eine halbe Stunde hochdrehen oder so.
Du kannst dir weitere Produkte für den Preis-Champ wünschen, ja. Da mache ich vielleicht
einen Tracker für, beziehungsweise einen Issue-Dings, wo man das aufmachen kann.
Das Problem ist, aktuell verwende ich einen Crawler, der ist fertig. Den kann ich zwar
erweitern, aber da habe ich jetzt noch nicht so viel Bock drauf. Aber wenn es da viel Nachfrage
gibt, kann ich das machen. Cookie-Banner brauchen wir nicht, hat keine
Cookies. Keine Cookies, kein Tracking, also kein User, kein Unique-User mit irgendwie
ID-Tracking. Der hat nichts, wozu man irgendwelche Banner machen muss. Kein Cookie-Banner, kein
DSGVO-Banner. By the way, Cookie-Banner ist eh das überflüssigste überhaupt. Die merkt
er sich den Dark Mode, Local Storage, das ist ja kein Cookie. Ach stimmt, stimmt, Cookies
haben wir nicht. Ich sehe da auch ein Cookie, ja, hier, da.
Können wir unsere Wünsche als User-Stories im Daily-Sprint-Planning äußern? Oh, das
ist eine gute Idee. Ich finde, das würde wahrscheinlich vortrefflich horizontal skalieren.
Der Dark Mode, du klickst auf den Keks. Wenn du auf den Keks klickst, kannst du zwischen
Dark Mode und Light Mode wechseln. Okay, das lassen wir jetzt erstmal so, Leute. Was verdient
man nach der Ausbildung? Kommt darauf an, in welchem Gebiet in Deutschland, was du kannst,
bei welcher Firma. Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen. Und hängt natürlich aus dem
Anschein davon ab, was du kannst und was nicht. Kann man, wunderbar, machen wir. Wir sollten
noch verschiedene Tribes einteilen. Ach ja, habt ihr überhaupt die ITIL-Zertifizierung?
Weil ich arbeite prinzipiell nicht mit Leuten ohne ITIL-Zertifizierung zusammen. Ich hoffe,
das ist klar. Und DIN ISO 9001 darf auch nicht fehlen. Nur mit zertifizierten Profis wird
hier gearbeitet. Da könnte theoretisch auch eBay, ja. Ist Preis-Cham-Programmieren was
ein DevOps ist? Nein, das mache ich nicht auf der Arbeit. Ich mache ehrlich gesagt eher
solche Dinger hier in die Richtung auf der Arbeit. Obwohl Dockerfiles nicht unbedingt
meine Spezialität ist, wie man gesehen hat. Ich mache zum Beispiel relativ viel Server-Automaten,
wobei es heißt nicht bei Server-Automaten. Sorry Leute. Infrastructure as Code, bitte
schön. Server-Automatisierung, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Infrastructure as Code mache
ich natürlich. Ayak. Ayak. Als nächstes wird CACW as a Service programmiert. Einfach
nur aufrufen und es gibt immer einen random CACW-Image zurück. Wie lange streamst du
noch? Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt off gehen. Leute, es war nice, dass ihr dabei wart. Aber
ich habe Hunger und ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen. Und vorher, bevor ich off gehe,
ich gehe jetzt zu meinen Hetzenas-Servern und ich power die off. Wobei, vielleicht brauche
ich ja da noch was von. Was kann man unter Infrastructure as Code, was damit gemeint
ist, wenn du zum Beispiel täglich neue Server aufbaust und die brauchen alle mehr oder weniger
das gleiche, dann könntest du natürlich auf jeden Server drauf gehen und dort immer
die gleichen Sachen von Hand installieren. Oder, so wie man es früher gemacht hat, man
hat eben einen Installer-Script gehabt und das hat dann stur die Sachen runter installiert.
Wenn es aber ein bisschen komplizierter wird, du hast zum Beispiel 20 verschiedene Server-Typen,
Web-Server, Datenbank-Server, Applikationsserver.net, Applikationsserver Java, Applikationsserver
Kobol, was auch immer, die teilweise auch eine gemeinsame Base haben, teilweise nicht,
da sind die Abhängigkeiten schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Und du hast im Endeffekt das,
was man früher mit so einem Server-Setup-Script gemacht hat, machst du damit etwas ausgefeilteren
Tools und dazu kommt heute noch sowas wie Chef genau, Ansible Chef, Puppet gibt ja
ein paar Dinge. Und was heute noch dazu kommt, dass auch dynamisch Server erzeugt werden
müssen, also können werden müssen. Linux only, mit Windows mache ich nichts. Also zum
Beispiel, dass du sagen kannst, ok, wir haben jetzt keine Ahnung, 6 Server für die und
die App und das reicht nicht mehr, jetzt machen wir 12. Da kannst du ja nicht erstmal hingehen
von Hand, übertrieben gesagt, die Debian-CD, die Retter-CD reinlegen, das Ding installieren
und dann von Hand eintippen. Das muss dann alles automatisch gehen. Im Prinzip ein bisschen
so wie das bei Hetzner unter der Haube hier auch funktioniert, dass du auf den Knopf
drückst und du hast einen Server am Start, mit basic Sachen schon drauf. Nur, dass wir
halt die Details von den Servern auch in so einem Konfigurationsmanagement-System drin
haben, soll es einem Infrastructure-as-Code-System natürlich, dass wir zum Beispiel auch irgendeinen
Datenbank-Server, der kaputt ist, einfach schnell wieder hinstellen kann. Kannst du
Hetzner empfehlen? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, ist günstig, Art Wumms, kann man es echt
nicht beschweren. Ach ja, übrigens eine Sache muss ich noch mal machen. Moment, networks,
nicht networks, floating IPs, unassign, unassign, meine ganzen IPs löschen. Oh fuck. Alter,
gehst du mal weg. Kann man es auch einfach löschen? Ah, viel besser. Kann es da unten
mal weggehen, das ist ja eklig. Oh, das ist nervig. Das ist huge, huge nervig. Netcup
habe ich mir auch angeguckt, die haben ein bisschen mehr Traffic. Allerdings hat Hetzner
ja auch nur inbound-Traffic erzählt. Ich weiß nicht, was gefällt dir bei Netcup, warum
würdest du das vorziehen? Günstiger, aber viel Unterschied kann doch nicht sein. Oder
wir gucken jetzt mal, ich gucke mal gleich. Was isst du gleich? Keine Ahnung. Warum willst
du das wissen? Wie sicher ist so ein Hetzner-Server in der Standard-Config? Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Du solltest halt nach Möglichkeit beim Server erstellen. Wenn du den Server hinzufügst,
du sollst nach Möglichkeiten erst das Haki von dir geeditert haben und den gleich drauf
machen und am besten gleich noch nach dem Login-Root-Passport ausschalten. Aber selbst wenn du das
nicht machst, du kannst bei Hetzner den Server starten und der ist nach so normalen Standards
absolut in Ordnung abgesichert. Ja, Digital Ocean habe ich früher öfters verwendet, auch
hier ein paar Mal im Stream. Das, wo wir das mit den Open-Street-View-Karten gemacht haben
zum Beispiel. Aber Hetzner kostet halt nur die Hälfte. Das ist schon ein Argument,
da musst du zugeben. Netcup. Okay, wir vergleichen jetzt mal die Preise. Also hier sehen wir
die Preise mal von Hetzner-Preise. Okay, vergleichen wir mal. Netcup. Preising, Preising, wo ist
das Preising? Kannst du Flashhost ausprobieren? Es gibt 30 Milliarden Hoster, ich kann die
nicht alle testen, aber ich kann mal in die Preise reingucken, weil ich dazu sage. Flashhost.in.
Umgebote einsehen. Okay, das ist KVM wie bei Hetzner. Okay, das ist ungefähr doppelt
so teuer wie Hetzner. Ungefähr doppelt so teuer. Ja, also das kostet ungefähr das Doppelte.
Was ist die fetteste? Die fetteste ist nur 6 Kerne für 23. Nee, also Hetzner ist halt
preisleistungsmäßig, was das angeht, echt unschlagbar. Ionos, habe ich einen 1-Euro-Server,
aber ich habe da keinen E-Mail-Postfächer. Ach so, testen. Kann ich jetzt nicht machen,
bin ich nicht eingeloggt. So, mal direkter Vergleich. Der günstigste 4-Kerner kostet
13.99, Hetzner kostet der günstigste 4-Kerner. Guck mal, dafür lohnt sich das natürlich.
Guck mal hier, das ist gar nicht mal übel. Je nachdem, was man will, da lohnt sich wirklich
zu gucken. Guck mal hier, hier ist der günstigste 4-Kerner, ist 13.99 monatlich. Hier geht er
los bei 14.6, im Prinzip das gleiche. 8G RAM und hier hast du 6G RAM, ein bisschen mehr
Platte und Traffic. Was hast du hier für Traffic? Unlimited. Traffic, ok. Ja. Also für die Mittelpreisdinger
ist es tatsächlich nicht übel. Und 16 Kerne bei 20, 8G. Ja, also die zwei kleinen lohnen
sich nicht so, aber die 4-Kerner machen vom, also der da und der da. Also 3 und 5 macht
eigentlich einen ganz passablen Eindruck. Bläschloss ist Instagram, den kenne ich nicht. Mich
hat nur einer nach den Preisen gefragt, also das sieht von den Preisen in Ordnung aus.
Was machst du mit dem Jonos Presence Detection für mein iPhone? Würdest du eher mehrere
kleine VPS oder einen großen VPS, je nachdem was günstiger ist. Wenn du natürlich jetzt
was hast, wo sich das anbietet, wenn du zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, ein Load Balancer
und zwei App Server haben willst, dann würde ich eher kleine nehmen, aber das kommt drauf
an, ja. Man kann aber auch ganz ehrlich, selbst wenn der 16-Kerner günstiger ist und du quasi
es nicht aus Hochverfügbarkeitszwecken des Cloud-Anbieters machst, sondern nur wegen,
also wenn du nicht davon ausgehst, dass der mehr abscheißt als zwei und nicht bedeuten
mehr, dann kannst du es auch so machen, dass du beispielsweise deine App einfach zweimal
im Container startest oder zweimal nebeneinander startest und auf deinem Server ein Load Balancer
davor machst. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie war es bei NetCap, die Preise? Zeit mal her.
Das hatte ich mir letzten schon mal angeguckt. Server, tellst du deine Videos auch auf YouTube
oder darf man nicht? Ich mache echt viele Videos auf YouTube. Allerdings hauptsächlich
halt etwas massenkompatiblere Themen, also ich glaube ich kann auf YouTube keine 4,5
Stunden, Max ist zu doof, Docker Files zu schreiben, Stream hochladen. Das funktioniert
glaub nicht. Höchstens so einen Zusammenschnitt, so einen Zusammenschnitt könnte man vielleicht
machen. Ne, aber wir haben dann Archiv, wenn du dich für alte Streams interessierst, wir
haben dann Archiv. Wupplos.tv, Archiv und dann kommst du bei einem Google Drive raus,
dann hast du hier einen Textdokument, wo alle Streamnamen drin stehen, die ich je gemacht
hab und hier die jeweiligen Jahresordner, wo man sich die Streams angucken kann. Ja,
das ist doch Gleichspiel und ich will das nicht hochladen, weil es keinen interessiert
auf YouTube, das ist total wirr, das kannst du nicht machen. In den Preis-Champ werde
ich auf jeden Fall noch auf YouTube vorstellen. Guckt und das coole ist an so Cloud-Servern,
die minütlich oder minütlich, sekundlich, wie auch immer, abgerechnet werden. Jetzt
haben wir einen Server erstellt, haben damit ganz gut was ausprobiert und der hat am Ende
2 Cent gekostet und der andere hat an uns gekostet 6 Cent. Also Leute wir haben 8 Cent
heute Serverkosten gehabt. Anzeige ist raus, da brauche ich jetzt mindestens 5 Prime-Subs
dafür, dass ich das wieder reinkriege, sonst kann ich meine Internetrechnung nicht bezahlen.
Oh, hier Leute, nicht öffnen, nicht öffnen. Sieht man da irgendwelche Abrechnungen bei
Usage? Zum Glück nicht. Okay, wir haben heute, wir haben heute 18 Cent verbraucht im Stream
Leute, ganze 18 Cent. Ich will da jetzt nicht draufklicken, aber was ist das für ein Knopf?
Danke schön für den Sub. Share your link. Oh, Headstart-Partner-Programm. Da muss ich,
da muss ich, da muss ich rein, da muss ich ran Leute. Easy Money, easy life, Headstart-Partner-Programm,
auf geht's. Musst du nicht noch den Snapshot löschen? Oh ja, gute, gute Idee. Okay, Netcar-Preise
wollte ich mir angucken noch, ja. Du musst die Server löschen, ausschalten bringt nichts,
du musst die wirklich löschen. Das heißt, wenn du regelmäßig immer mal wieder einen
Server brauchst, dann ist zum Beispiel, ist wirklich sinnvoll, also nicht preischamp.de.
Beta.preischamp.org musst du machen hier. Beta.preischamp.org. Oh, Cloudflare hat rumgebackt
Leute. So, Netcar, also. Was haben die am Start? Ein Core, okay, das ist ziemlich exakt
das was der Kram bei Hetzner auch kostet. Also das nimmt sich nichts, 2,96 und hier
kostet es 2,69, also das ist jetzt 30 Cent oder so, 27 Cent. So, günstigste 2 Core,
15. Da muss man echt genau gucken, also. Je nachdem was man haben will lohnt sich das
halt dann unterschiedlich, ja. Hier kriegst du auch 440, hier kriegst du auch 440. Das
ist halt, ja, bisschen unterschiedlicher. Also wenn man wirklich den allergünstigsten
haben will, dann sind die hier ein bisschen billiger. Naja, aber bei Netcar ist der Traffic
glaube ich in und out, oder? Bei Hetzner ist der Traffic nur, äh, nur out, nee, äh,
also nur out, also sprich inbound ist unlimited. Das heißt du kriegst, du kriegst im Endeffekt
die 20 Terabyte gar nicht wirklich, äh, wirklich voll, ja. So, also was haben die
sonst noch schönes? Äh, 2 Core, der günstigste 4 Core ist 11, hier ist der günstigste 4 Core
14. Dafür, ok, die günstigsten Server lohnen sich dann immer anscheinend. Was haben die
das fetteste hier? 16 Kerne, 40 Euro. Hier sind, hier sind 16 Kerne, Moment, das kann
nicht sein, das kann nicht sein. Moment, aaah, das ist Jebait, das ist Jebait, Leute.
Aber die haben doch auch stündliche Abrechnung, oder? Jaja, das ist stündliche Abrechnung,
würde ich sagen. Alter, das ist, ja, aber das ist ja total bescheuert. Das kannst du
ja überhaupt nicht vergleichen, kannst du das global wenigstens ausschalten? Das ist
ja, oah, das ist ja fies. Ach, der ist stundenbasiert, ok, das passt. Der ist stundenbasiert. Der
anscheinend auch. Der ist auch stundenbasiert. Und alle anderen stimmen nicht von den Zahlen
her. Er kostet nämlich 14,30 der 4-Core. Ja, und dann macht es wieder keinen großen
Unterschied. Aha. Aber das ist schon auf jeden Fall verwirrend, das sollten sie gleich anzeigen.
Abrechnungsperiode 3 Monate, ok, es wird stündlich abgerechnet, aber das wird dann so aufsummiert,
dass du in 3 Monaten verwendet hast oder so, ok. Also ganz ehrlich, warum nicht gleich
bei Hetzner? Preislich ist kein großer Unterschied, da ist wenigstens durchsichtig. So, was haben
wir für Roots? Aber AMD, Epic. 2 Kerne, 4 Kerne, 6 Kerne, 10 Kerne, ok. Na, das brauche
ich nicht. Mir reicht die VPS-Geschichte, Digga, aus. AWS ist in der Regel relativ teuer,
was VMs angeht im Vergleich zu sowas hier. Was hatten deine AWS-VM für Specs? Oder hast
du eine SQL-Datenbank SS-Service von AWS quasi? Das ist ja wieder was ganz anderes dann.
Ah, du hast, du bezahlt, du kümmerst dich quasi nicht um den Server, sondern du benutzt
einfach nur den Service, ja gut. Steht da irgendwie dabei, was die so für Performance-Sachen
hat, weil ansonsten kann man es echt schwer vergleichen. Also bei Hetzner würdest du
zum Beispiel, oder hier bei Letka oder dem anderen, da kriegst du für 15 Euro im Monat
einen 4-Kerner mit 8 GB RAM und 160 GB SSD. Wie groß kann deine Festplatte, wie groß
kann deine Datenbank werden? Also so eine Datenbank SS-Service-Geschichte kannst du
schlecht mit so einem VPS vergleichen. Man könnte vielleicht höchstens mal sagen, wie
groß darf die, also Maximum an Daten drinne und wie viel garantiert das RAM. Das steht
ja bei Datenbanken meistens dabei. MySQL-Pricing, okay gucken wir mal. Kann man aber echt schlecht
vergleichen. Ich vermute mal, du würdest mit so einem Hetzner sogar günstiger wegkommen,
weil AWS-Dinger nicht die billigsten Sachen sind. Okay, also was gibt es da jetzt? Ich
checke es nicht. AWS ist auch echt unübersichtlich. What the fuck, Alter? Ich bin blind. Da blickste
ich nicht durch. Okay, wie viel Speicher bekommt man? Ah, das ist auch dynamisch, okay. Sorry,
das kann ich dir nicht beantworten. Dafür finde ich AWS zu unübersichtlich an der Sache
jetzt. Ah, hier kann man, Preis pro Stunde. Ja, aber woher weiß ich denn was, was ist?
DB-M5-Large. Woher weiß ich denn jetzt was DB, woher weiß ich denn jetzt was DB, keine
Ahnung, DB-M6G-Dings-Large eigentlich ist? Du hast Mikro, ja gut, aber woher weiß ich
denn was das ist? Woher weiß ich was da dahinter steckt? Leuchtet überhaupt nicht ein. Also
AWS checke ich nicht, ohne Scheiß, das ist mir zu. Ach hier, guck mal, Anzahl Cores,
zwei CPUs, ein G. Okay, es ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich, also du bekommst zwei, du
hast, was ist denn CPU-Gutschriften? AWS 5 Euro für ein SSH Key? Keg-Wade? Warum?
So viel fällt mir nur zu AWS Sachen ein. Ach so, den Speicher, ja gut, das macht Azure
auch. Sobald du die Shell startest, brauchst du Speicher und bezahlst Storage. Also wenn
ihr nichts habt auf Azure und ihr startet die Azure Shell, kostet es schon Geld. Die
wissen was geht. So, also, du bezahlst, wie viel bezahlst du? 15 Euro dafür. So, du bekommst,
okay, was sind CPU-Gutschriften dann nochmal? Ich nehme keine Ahnung. Den Calculator kenne
ich. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was CPU-Gutschriften sind. Ist das was, das du mal mehr verbrauchen
kannst? Okay, also, wir gehen jetzt mal von dem aus, du bezahlst 15 Euro im Monat, du
kriegst im Prinzip zwei CPU-Kerne und ein Gigabyte RAM. Hier kriegst du für 15 Euro
8 Gigabyte RAM und 4 CPU-Kerne. Also, da hast du auf jeden Fall mehr Wumms, musst dich
aber halt um deinen Server selbst kümmern. Ja, das Problem ist, ja, das ist gut. Ja,
das ist halt der Vorteil von Datenbanken erstes Service. Die ist einfach da und geht und bei
der anderen musst du sie selbst kümmern. Aber ganz im Ernst, viel musst du, also viel
musst du da nicht machen. Also, wenn du jetzt nicht vorhast, das irgendwie ultra zu scalen
und dann morgen auf einmal 60 Server brauchst oder so, viel musst du nicht machen. Du nimmst
dir irgendwie die Kiste hier. Guck mal, ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre das hier
großartig schwer. Du gehst hierhin, sagst, du hast hier ein Rechenzentrum aus, nimmst
Ubuntu, dann nimmst du hier die günstigste Vierkerne-Kiste und willst dein SSH-Key aus,
fertig. Ja, das stimmt, na klar, na klar. Das ist der Vorteil davon. Das ist der Vorteil
davon, klar. Das bezahlt man halt auch dementsprechend. Bei dem Server müsstest du im Endeffekt noch
nicht, du müsstest da noch nicht mal großartig Sicherheitsupdates, also ich will jetzt dir
nicht empfehlen, das nicht zu machen, ja, aber wenn du da nur SSH-offen hast, äh, ja,
da gibt es nicht so viele Einfalltore. Ich würde automatische Sicherheitsupdates wahrscheinlich
anmachen. Ähm, tja, gut, das MySQL müsstest du dann exposen im Internet, das kannst du
wahrscheinlich in AWS-Intern irgendwie machen. Allerdings, ja, gut, ist halt Geschmackssache,
ja. Ich habe meinen Kram hier, das Ding, den Preistracker, den habe ich auf einem
Hetzer-Server laufen und heute im Stream habe ich halt auch geguckt, dass ich das Deployment
irgendwie automatisch hinbekomme, dass es dann ein bisschen angenehmer ist. Ähm, ob
du, ich weiß nicht, ob du Hetzer über Terraform ansprechen kannst, mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn das geht, weil Hetzer hat eine Cloud API und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es
da zumindest vielleicht irgendwelche Zusatzmöglichkeiten gibt. Ja, geht. Habe ich ja nicht gemacht,
aber war zu erwarten, wie gesagt, die machen auch dick Werbung für ihre Cloud API.
So, nice. Ok, also wie gesagt, mehr kann ich da nichts zu sagen zu den AWS-Dingern. Also
ich habe bisher nur Azure und Dings verwendet, GCP und bei GCP auch keine VMs oder sonst
andere Geschichten. Wir können übrigens mal gucken, was das kostet. Ach, das ist auch
undurchsichtig. Also ich habe da keine Server verwendet, ich habe halt so Google API Scheiß
verwendet, ja. Location, Reverse Lookup und Straßenvervollständigung und ach, was für
einen Szenzen habe ich nur Azure verwendet bisher und das hat auch so seine Tücken gesehen,
nicht, weil ich der ultrakrasse Azure-Profi-Hack-Sorwer. Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, von dem
ganzen Zeug, was ich bisher gesehen habe, rein mal jetzt mal, wie es die Noobs machen,
auch mal aufs GUI bezogen. Ich meine, Azure ist auch ein übelst undurchsichtiges Ding,
aber ich finde es noch am, also im Vergleich zu Google, noch tickenübersichtlicher und
AWS habe ich nichts großartig mitgemacht. Aber alles, was ich bisher von AWS gesehen
habe, ist total kompliziert. Ich checke bei AWS nichts. Wenn ich bei AWS gucken will, ey,
was kostet das, dann hast du ja eben wieder gesehen, wir haben uns über fünf Seiten geschickt
und blickst nicht durch. Was ist eigentlich mit dem Tool, wo du die Straßen, das haben
wir nicht weiterentwickelt. Das läuft, aber das haben wir nicht weiterentwickelt. Die machen
das übrigens absichtlich, dass das Pricing so kompliziert ist und man konnte ja lange
Zeit noch nicht mal Limits anlegen. Sag mal, funktioniert überhaupt die Alertfunktion?
Ja, die funktioniert. Wenn du es aktiviert hast, du siehst doch die Glocke hier, guck
mal. Du siehst doch die Glocke, ob du es aktiviert hast. Wir könnten oben noch ein
AlertActive einblenden. Die Glocke macht bei dir nichts. Was verwendest du für einen Browser
und was verwendest du für eine Plattform? Chrome Windows? Was? Chrome Windows? Hast
du vielleicht Notifications verboten? Hast du Notifications verboten auf der Seite? Dann
geht es nämlich nicht. Also ich fake mal einen neuen Besuch auf der Seite. Zack, wenn
du hier drauf gehst und die Glocke drückst. Äh. Äh. Äh. Moment. Warte. Warte. Warte.
Moment. Wie haben sie so letzten Sonntag Windows ausprobiert?
Warum geht das nicht? Und warum geht das im Firefox?
Hm. Warum geht das mit dem...
Kann das sein, dass es nur privat nicht geht? Ich meine, warum geht das im Chrome? Moment,
ich bin jetzt echt, echt verwirrt. Ah, das sollte eigentlich so ein Popup kommen. Das
sollte eigentlich so ein Popup kommen. Das geht im Incognito Modus nicht. Ja doch, funktioniert
gut. Aber Incognito geht es wahrscheinlich nicht. Ah, wenn man das Incognito aufmacht,
kann man keine Notifications machen. Okay. Aber ansonsten geht es. Edge? Edge? Was für
ein Servo ist Ubuntu? Netscape Navigate. Hallol. Notifications easy. Ah, weil die Notifications
geblockt hast. Okay, jetzt ergibt es Sinn. Aber es wäre vielleicht wirklich nicht schlecht.
Was haltet ihr davon, wenn man einfach auch auf der Seite Notifications einblendet? Irgendwie
hier unten so ein Popup macht oder so. Wobei, das braucht man eigentlich nicht. Die Notifications
könnten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser machen und noch einen Preis in die Notifications
schreiben. Okay, Edge, halt die Klappe. Jaja, Edge ist gut, es ist gut. What the? Warum gehen
die Notifications nicht mehr aus? Sind die jetzt aus? Ah, guck mal, jetzt ist nichts
mehr angegangen. Bei mir geht das Sound auch nur im Edge lustigerweise.
Du musst die Notifications, glaube ich, einmal wegklicken. Wie gesagt, der Preischamp verwendet
Ubuntu. Das ist Buggy. Mach mal aus und reloade die Seite oder irgendwas. Z.B. dann macht
es die Notifications-Settings aus. Es kann sein, dass das noch ein bisschen verbackt
ist, wobei das mit den Notifications eigentlich immer ganz gut geklappt hat. Ich habe es
aber auch nicht oft angehabt. So Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen, ich habe Hunger. Moment,
die Glocken durchgestrichen heißt, dass du alle Notifications anhast. Das ist Notifications
aus. Okay, das ist gut zu wissen, dass das auch Leute verwirren kann. Also das Eigen
zeigt an, was die Aktion macht, wenn du draufklickst. Also standardmäßig ist es so und so ist es
nicht. Vielleicht sollte ich das umdrehen. Nee, das ist umgedreht. Vielleicht sollte
ich die Dinger inverten, dass standardmäßig aus ist und ja, ich inverte die. Ich glaube,
das ist besser. Wir könnten eine Message machen, die einfällt, Notification aktiviert. Genau,
wir machen einfach hier unten so ein Toast oder so. Was hat jemand vorgeschlagen? Toastr.
Das gibt es in Viewtify bestimmt schon eingebaut. Toastr. Nebelhorn. Ich kann an den Sounds nichts
ändern. Die Sounds des Windows OS spezifisch. Toastr ist off. Kein Bock mehr. Radio Button.
Wir könnten einen Switch machen. Aber so ist doch okay. Also wenn ich die standardmäßig
auf durchgestrichen mache. Macht doch die deaktivierten Eigens. Ja, ja. Ich schreibe
das mal auf. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich mache das in Wörter. Ich drehe das einfach um.
Drehe das einfach um. In der neuen Version haben wir es ja auch schon gemacht, dass man
die Pop-Ups hier mit einem Klick auf das ganze Ding aufmachen kann. Okay Leute, ich
gehe jetzt wirklich was essen. Also Leute, wir sehen uns. Machts gut. Bis denn. See you.